Lieber Fritz, jetzt eigentlich vergessen, wie man den Kalender richtig liest. Ist doch noch gar nicht der letzte Mittwoch im Monat und trotzdem kommt Chaosradio. Richtig, richtig, richtig. Chaosradio ist hier, 20. August 2008, kurz nach 10. Wir haben Teil 138. Steini und Frank Rieder sind zu Gast. Grüße euch.
Ja, ich wünsche auch einen schönen guten Abend.
Wir sind hier, weil dieser Tage morgen die offizielle Games Convention in Leipzig eröffnet und die Gamechecker von Fritz darum gebeten haben, den Spiele-Blumboon, der eigentlich heute stattfinden sollte, auf die nächste Woche zu schieben, weil ansonsten hätten sie nämlich heute nichts zu erzählen gehabt und können nächste Woche mit euch über die aktuellen Entwicklungen in Sachen Zockerei reden. Also deswegen ausnahmsweise Chaosradio mal nicht am letzten, sondern am heutigen Freitag im Monat. Ansonsten bleibt alles beim Alten.
Heute geht's Mittwoch.
Wieso bin ich eigentlich bei Freitag? Ja, oder schon wieder angefangen. Das kann durchaus natürlich sein. Wir reden heute über eine abgefahrene Geschichte und zwar über unbemannte und autonom sich bewegende Geräte, unter anderem Drohnen.
Genau. Das ist ein Trend, den wir in den letzten Jahren immer wieder verfolgt haben, auf dem Kongress schon behandelt haben. Die Computer sind schnell genug geworden, die Sensoren sind gut genug geworden. Wir haben starke Elektromotoren, wir haben starke Akkumulatoren. Deswegen gibt es immer mehr Computer, die auf vier Beinen laufen oder mit vier Propellern durch die Gegend fliegen. Darüber wollen wir uns heute ein bisschen unterhalten, was so viele Folgen hat. Ein bisschen Robotik auch im Allgemeinen, wohin geht die Reise, welchen Ausblick können wir wagen und auch darüber, wie man selber damit basteln kann, was wir so an Aktivitäten haben. Da gibt es die sogenannten Quadrocopter, da wollen wir uns heute ein bisschen darüber unterhalten.
Wir haben ja vor ziemlich genau einem Jahr schon mal Hands-on, hieß die Sendung damals, das letzte Mal, als ich hier war.
Da war Quadrocopter auch ein Thema.
Genau, da war Quadrocopter zumindest auch ein kleines Thema. Können wir auch mal gucken, für alle, die die Sendung gesehen haben, was sich seitdem verändert hat, wie es weitergegangen ist, sicher auch spannend.
Die Rede ist natürlich hauptsächlich immer von Drohnen. Du sprichst gerade von sich autonom bewegenden Computern, die immer leistungsfähiger werden und sich bewegen.
Ist das dasselbe? Ja, so eine Drohne, die gibt es ja schon sehr lange. Die ersten Drohnen sind ja im Zweiten Weltkrieg gebaut worden, also noch sehr mechanisch, mit sehr wenig Elektronik. Eigentlich Programm- oder Programmscheiben-gesteuerte Flugobjekte, was es war, waren Flugzeuge oder auch Raketen, in denen sich so eine Scheibe langsam drehte, die halt unförmig war. Und jede Beule an dieser Scheibe hat dann die Ruder an dem Flugobjekt gekippt. Das heißt, es ist sozusagen eine Flugbahn nach Zeit abgerflogen. Dann gab es noch ein bisschen Kompensation nach Kompasskurs und solchen Sachen. Also da wurde schon relativ viel dran gebaut. Natürlich ist diese Entwicklung primär im militärischen Bereich zu suchen. Also man wollte halt irgendwie Sprengstoff ins Ziel bringen oder Fotoapparate über das Gegende des Territoriums fliegen. Die Amerikaner haben da sehr viel Zeit und Geld investiert, um über diese Wetternähe und die Chinesen zu fliegen. Das waren aber immer sehr große, sehr teure Projekte. In den letzten Jahren ist es so, dass gerade die militärische Drohnenforschung enormen Aufschwung genommen hat, soweit es auch gerade wieder zu sehen in Georgien, also mit dem Georgien-Konflikt, als der losging. So die ersten Zeichen, dass es jetzt wirklich langsam ernst wird, war, als die Russen eine georgische Drohne da über Abhrasingen, glaube ich, abgeschossen und die Bilder dann auch davon zu sehen waren. Dann sieht man halt einfach nur so fast nichts. Da fliegt halt irgendwas und sendet halt ein Fernsehbild runter und wurde plötzlich abgeschossen. Und das findet halt immer mehr statt. Also eigentlich in allen militärischen Konflikten, die gerade so stattfinden, werden diese Drohnen in großem Umfang verwendet, auch im Irak und Afghanistan. Überall da, wo Flugzeuge zu teuer sind oder der Einsatz von Flugzeugen zu gefährlich wäre oder man einfach nicht genug Flugzeuge hat. So, das ist halt sehr üblich. Und der Grund, warum das meistens fliegt, ist halt einfach, dass da weniger Dinge zum Gegenfliegen sind, als auf dem Boden zum Gegenlaufen. Das heißt, es ist einfacher, autonom zum Fliegen zu bringen, als autonom zum Laufen.
Ja, warum sich das jetzt demnächst ändern wird, das wollen wir noch in aller Gänze betrachten. Frank hat es schon gesagt, die Entwicklung der Sensoren ist stark vorangegangen. Da haben wir auch ein paar Beispiele, ein paar Anregungen, auch was da noch werden kann. Das wird sehr spannend.
Vor allen Dingen ist es also eines der Themen dieser Sendung. Wir wollen ja nicht nur unbedingt über militärische Technik reden, die da irgendwo im Einsatz ist, sondern man kann sich so eine Dinge für relativ schmales Budget auch selber bauen. Und da sind wir dann eigentlich bei dem Grund, bei dem Punkt, über den wir mit euch auch gerne heute reden würden. Wo führt es eigentlich alles hin, wenn sich jeder seine eigene kleine Überwachungsmaschine baut, bzw. wenn ihr abends einfach im Bad steht, vielleicht jetzt um kurz nach 10 euch die Zähne putzt und plötzlich brummt es vor dem Fenster und der Nachbar fliegt euch eine Drohne rein und guckt euch ins Badezimmer. Das ist dann der Punkt, wo man ernsthaft drüber nachdenken sollte, ob sowas überhaupt noch cool ist oder nicht. Ihr könnt mitdiskutieren, 0331 70 97 110 ist die Telefonnummer oder aber chaosradio.ctc.de. Da gibt es einen Link zum Chat, da könnt ihr gerne auch mitmachen und euch hier am Chaos Radio heute beteiligen. Wollen wir gleich einsteigen mit den Quadrokoptern oder die hier?
Ich erzähl nochmal für alle, die es vor einem Jahr nicht gehört haben oder es schon wieder vergessen haben. Quadrokoptern oder den Podcast gelöscht haben oder den Podcast gelöscht haben oder einfach jetzt erst zugeschaltet haben. Quadrokopter heißt Quadrokopter, weil es im Prinzip ein Helikopter mit vier Rotoren ist, von denen zwei links rum und zwei rechts rum drehen. Das macht man, damit die sich nicht ständig im Kreis kreiseln. Das wäre unpraktisch. Ganz gut daran ist, dass man keinen Heckrotor braucht, wie beim Hubschrauber, der das Ding sozusagen in einer geraden Flugrichtung hält, sondern tatsächlich alle Rotoren zum Auftrieb beitragen oder wenn man das Ding schräg nach vorne stellt zum Vortrieb, sodass hier keine wesentliche Energie verschwendet wird. Außerdem wahnsinnig praktisch daran ist, und das macht es auch so leicht, zu selbst zu bauen, dass man nicht wie beim Hubschrauber Verstellrotoren braucht, also dass das Hauptrotorblatt in der Neigung verstellt werden kann, um eben Auftrieb bzw. Vortrieb zu erzeugen, sondern man das einfach dadurch macht, wenn man nach vorne fliegen will, macht man den hinteren Propeller ein bisschen schneller, dann kippt das Ding nach vorne und nimmt Fahrt auf. Gleiches gilt für links und rechts.
Also Prinzip Paddelboot eigentlich. Du paddelst links langsamer und es dreht sich dann rum.
So im Prinzip, beziehungsweise eben ich will eine Neigung nach vorne erzielen, damit es vorwärts fliegt oder nach links fließt oder nach rechts fließt, da muss ich nur den entsprechenden Rotor schneller und den gegenüber langsamer machen, dann kippt das Ding. Ich kann das also komplett mechanikfrei durch die Rotationsgeschwindigkeit der Propeller steuern. Das ist mit modernen Brushless-Motoren und die machen es überhaupt erst richtig möglich, so ein Ding effizient zum Einsatz zu bringen. Aber wenn man es mal hat, leicht möglich, also heutige Technik macht es tatsächlich sehr einfach. Ich brauche jetzt im Prinzip nur noch einen Mikrocontroller, also einen kleinen Prozessor, der eben die Sensoren verarbeitet und jeweils einem der vier Propellern sagt, was er jetzt tun soll.
Das klingt alles total kompliziert, wie schwer ist es wirklich, so ein Ding selber zu bauen? Bausatz gibt es für irgendwas zwischen 600 und 800 Euro?
Ja, wenn man es selber löten will, ist man auch schon bei 400 Euro dabei. Für 600, 700 Euro kriegt man zum Beispiel von Mikrokopter, weil es mit K geschrieben ist, also mikrokopter.de bei Holger und Ingo, kriegt man so einen Komplettbausatz für 700 Euro. Der ist, wenn man weiß, an welchem Ende der Lötkolben heiß ist, in einem Tag zusammengebaut.
Und damit baut man sich eigentlich seine eigene kleine Überwachungskamera?
Ja, die Kamera ist nicht dabei, die muss man jetzt noch ranhängen, aber das ist im Prinzip alles vorbereitet. Das heißt, ein Fotoapparat vorzugsweise löst das Problem erst mal. Da ist eine SD-Karte drin, da kann ich jetzt Video aufzeichnen oder in einem Form Bilder machen. Da bin ich dabei. Wenn ich jetzt live sozusagen aus der subjektiven, aus der ich-Perspektive fliegen will, braucht man eine Funkkamera. Die sind aber auch nicht mehr so teuer, gibt es bei Konrad und ähnlichen Versandhandeln. Man ist auf jeden Fall für unter 1000 Euro bei einer selbstgebauten Flugmaschine, die nicht nur GPS-gestützt autonom fliegen kann, sondern die eben auch Videobilder nach Hause überträgt.
Also wir reden hier schon über eine Technik, die zwar eigentlich für die militärische Nutzen gebaut wurde, so wie Frank das gerade erklärt hat, aber die mittlerweile eigentlich von jedem zu Hause auf dem Küchentisch nachzubauen ist. Und wo noch nicht so richtig klar ist, wo es eigentlich alles hingeht.
Wo nicht richtig klar ist, woran, wo es eigentlich hingeht. Und das erfüllt uns natürlich erfahrungsgemäß und wie üblich mit Sorge.
Und Neugier?
Und Neugier beides, wobei ich ja uns mittlerweile als neu süchtig und nicht mehr nur einfach neugierig bezeichne. Aber es ist natürlich klar, wir müssen das verstehen. Wir können auch nur gegebenenfalls, so das so sein sollte, mit dem erhobenen Zeigefinger winken, wenn wir verstanden haben, worum es geht. Da sind wir noch nicht. Sprich, das, was wir heute im Stande sind zu bauen, ist noch nicht so gut wie das, was militärs oder kommerzielle Systeme zu bieten haben. Da muss man erst mal verstehen, wie machen die das und was folgt denn da raus und wo wird denn die Reise hingehen. Das Beste, um das zu verstehen, ist, es eben selbst zu bauen. Damit, und da möchte ich gleich auch nochmal die Kurve kriegen, damit wir da so ein bisschen die Fraktion der Modellbauer, die sehr sehr gut sind, solche Systeme zu bauen und fliegbar zu machen. Und die haben momentan eigentlich ganz groß den Hut auf in dieser Mikrokopter-Szene. Die aber, das sind erfahrungsgemäß nicht die besten Programmierer. Die wollen lieber fliegen. Die wollen Loopings fliegen, schöne Figuren fliegen.
Schicke Maschinen haben.
Schicke Maschinen haben, schön in der Nacht blinkern und so. Das finde ich auch ganz großartig. Sind aber nicht die gleichen Leute, die coole Software machen, damit die Dinger jetzt autonom fliegen. Und um die so ein bisschen zusammenzubringen, gibt es eine Veranstaltung, da reden wir nachher noch ein bisschen ausführlicher drüber, am 20. September die Motodrone in Fino-Furt auf dem Altmilitärflughafen, wo auch das Chaoscamp war. Da wird es eine Veranstaltung zu genau diesem Thema geben. Da gibt es Informationsveranstaltungen, Diskussionsveranstaltungen, Workshops. Und es wird dann auch, die wird jetzt nicht am 20. stattfinden. Die haben wir verschoben, erkläre ich nachher genauer warum, sondern viel später stattfindet eine Challenge, ein Wettbewerb. Und auf diesen Wettbewerb wird es darum gehen, tatsächlich autonom fliegende Systeme zu zeigen. Der wird dann auch mit einem hohen Preis versehen sein. Also the winner takes it all. Es gibt dann am Ende 20.000 Euro zu gewinnen. Also genug, um seine Investition auch dick wieder reinzukriegen. Um tatsächlich von Published Source Software herzustellen, die also auch bereit sind, über ihre Technologie zu reden, weil darum geht es.
Also das muss man vielleicht noch dazu sagen. Also der Kern dieser Challenge ist ja, nicht nur irgendwie irgendwelchen Industrie-Teams die Gelegenheit zu bieten, noch ein bisschen Kohle aufzuzocken, um zu zeigen, wie toll sie sind, sondern die Idee dahinter ist ja, den Stand des Wissens darüber zu verbreitern, und zwar den öffentlichen Stand des Wissens. Deswegen ist die Bedingung, dass du, wenn du teilnehmen willst und den Preis gewinnen willst, musst du halt die Hosen runterlassen und deinen Code publizieren, damit die anderen von dir lernen können, und einfach sich der Stand des Wissens darüber, was geht da eigentlich verbreitert. Momentan ist es halt so, dass ein Großteil dieser Forschung im militärischen nicht öffentlichen Bereich stattfindet, und wir teilweise schlicht gar nicht wissen, welche Möglichkeiten es da so gibt. Wir wissen halt, dass die großen Militärdrohnen 72 Stunden in der Luft bleiben können, ohne aufzutanken, und halt irgendwie so lange über irgendwelche Kriegsgebieten rumfliegen können, um aus 10 Kilometer Höhe irgendwas zu filmen. Aber wie jetzt die genauen detaillierten Kapazitäten aussehen, wissen wir nicht. Wir wissen teilweise einfach nicht, ob bestimmte Dinge möglich sind oder nicht möglich sind.
Also müsste sie, wie Stein auch gerade sagte, einfach ausprobieren.
Genau, also einfach so im Prinzip ausprobieren, was geht so, und es geht natürlich auch darum, darüber später noch mal Strategien zu entwickeln, was kann man dagegen tun, wenn so ein Ding plötzlich in meinem Garten fliegt?
Ein Wort noch zum Published Source. Es geht hier, damit das nicht verwechselt wird, das führte schon zu heftigen Diskussionen. Es geht nicht um Open Source. Es geht uns nicht darum, dass der Entwickler dieser Software seine Rechte frei gibt und jeder kann damit machen, was er will, sondern es geht, er behält tatsächlich seine Rechte. Die wollen wir auch nicht ankratzen. Es geht darum, dass man zu privaten Zwecken eben für die nächste Challenge auf dem Wissen des Gewinner-Systems aufbaut, damit nicht irgendwann sich einer abhebt und alle anderen programmieren hinterher. Da ist dann nichts wieder zu machen, sondern es geht wirklich um den Informationsgewinn. Die Rechte, die vollständigen Verwertungsrechte, damit da auch keine Berührungsängste von Teams entstehen, jetzt tatsächlich eigentlich auch sehr viel Arbeit da reinstecken würden. Die Verwertungsrechte bleiben beim Programmierer oder bei den Teams, aber sie müssen eben veröffentlicht werden, damit man das zu privaten Zwecken eben zum Erkenntnisgewinn weiterverwenden kann.
Okay, also wenn ich das jetzt mal ganz kurz zusammenfassen kann, im Moment haben die Modellbauer schlicht und ergreifend aufgrund ihrer Tätigkeit als Modellbauer bei fliegenden Objekten die Nase vorne, weil die das einfach schon lange machen.
Na klar, das ist eine Tradition.
Und die Leute, die sich quasi mit der Technik von autonom fliegenden Dingern beschäftigen, sind in den meisten Fällen einfach aus militärischer Schweigepflicht oder so, dürfen die einfach nicht sagen, wie es funktioniert. Und jetzt sagt ihr, okay, wir bauen sowas selber.
Genau. Und Software-Entwickler muss man in der Kurve, die man zieht, noch dazusagen, sind erfahrungsgemäß nicht die allerbesten Modellbauer.
Also braucht ihr euch gegenseitig?
Man braucht sich da gegenseitig und es ist schlau, sich da mal zusammenzusetzen und gemeinsam auch Teams zu bilden und zu sagen, okay, dem Thema nehmen wir uns jetzt an. Da bauen die Modellbauer gut fliegende Maschinen und die Software-Entwickler, die machen das, dass ich mit einer SSH rauf kann und Kommando geben.
Weil manchmal hast du ja so, der Handwerker redet nicht mit dem Künstler und der Künstler nicht mit dem Handwerker.
Ja, also ein Teil der Challenge der Motodrone ist, die verschiedenen Welten zusammen zu bekommen. Und gut, da ist der Club auch traditionell relativ gut darin, einfach verschiedene Welten zusammen zu bringen und Leute aus unterschiedlichen Ecken zusammen zu Aktivitäten zu bewegen.
Genau, eine Information dazu noch. Ich erzähl vielleicht kurz noch ein bisschen, was es alles geben wird. Wir werden da interessante Diskussionspartner haben aus Politik, Militär und Forschung.
Ob es Militär kommt, wissen wir noch nicht. Aber wir haben es zumindest mal gefragt.
Zumindest, wenn Sie jetzt wissen, dass ihr so was macht, könnt ihr wetten, dass Sie einfach mal vorbeikommen, um zu gucken, was Sie tun.
Wir haben sich schon gefragt, ob Sie nicht mehr vorbeikommen wollen, um sich mal zu rechtfertigen und zu sagen, warum Sie das jetzt eigentlich tun. Also was eigentlich der Grund dafür ist, dass Sie jetzt auch so eine Systeme setzen.
Diese Systeme sind ja nicht nur, um kurzen Einwurf zu machen, die sind ja nicht nur militär in der Verwendung, sondern auch bei der Polizei, bei Fußballspielen, bei großen Sportveranstaltungen, wo man einfach eine Überwachung, also von oben einfach gucken kann, wie viele Leute sind hier im Stadion, wer läuft gerade wohin und wer pinkelt gegen den Baum.
Genau, also das ist zumindest das, was Sie gerne wollen. Momentan sind es halt noch Feldversuche, wo Sie halt erstmal testen. Da gibt es halt eine Menge Schwierigkeiten. Aber wir wollen halt gerne mit Ihnen darüber reden. Wir wollen halt einfach gerne wissen, was denken Sie sich dabei? Warum denken Sie, dass Sie nicht mit den normalen, bisher vorhandenen Systemen auskommen und machen die sich eigentlich Gedanken darüber, wo die Reise dahin geht? Also denken Sie sich darüber, dass Sie über jeden Quadratkilometer statt so ein Ding hängen, um einfach uns flächendeckend zu überwachen? Oder um einfach da auch mal einen gewissen Dialog gerade mit der Politik hinzubekommen, versuchen wir da halt auch möglichst so eine Leute einzuladen.
Genau. Was wir weiter noch sehen werden, ist ein konkreten Workshop. Das heißt, wir werden vier solche Systeme an dem Tag zusammenbauen. Diese Bausätze, die werden wir dort vor Ort zusammenbauen. Man wird mit Leuten dort diskutieren können, die sowas auch schon mal gemacht haben, die auch Detailwissen haben. Deswegen wollen wir heute auch nicht zu technisch zu sehr ins Detail gehen, sondern eher über die Folgen sprechen.
Für die Technik gibt es einen Chaosradio Express?
Da gibt es einmal noch einen Chaosradio Express und natürlich die Veranstaltung selber, auf die jeder gerne eingeladen ist zu kommen und sich dort genau zu informieren, auch über die Technik. Und man wird sich dann auch hinterher, gerade die Software-Entwickler, die nicht so imstande sind, Modelle zu bauen, um eines der vier Systeme bewerben können. Wenn man denn ein vernünftiges Konzept hat, wie man an den Challenges teilnehmen will, kann man sich bewerben, darum zu sagen, ich bin beschissener Modellbauer, ich habe auch nicht genug Geld, um jetzt irgendein System zu kaufen. Ich habe aber eine Idee. Und wenn die plausibel genug ist, dann kann man sich so ein System zur Verfügung stellen lassen und darauf aufbauend eben seine Software entwickeln.
Okay, aber Motodrone ist sozusagen die Veranstaltung, die noch kommt, am 20. September. Heute wollen wir auch ein bisschen über so autonom fliegende, sich autonom bewegende Objekte. In dem Fall meistens eben Drohnen, also fliegende Geräte reden, weil, wie Frank schon sagte, das ist die einfachste Art und Weise, sowas durch die Gegend zu bewegen, weil du hast relativ wenig Hindernisse. Falls ihr euch jetzt fragt, na ja, und wo ist das Problem? Worüber soll man da diskutieren? Da gibt es jede Menge Angelpunkte und Fußnoten, über die es sich dringend lohnt, mal nachzudenken und zu diskutieren. Das wollen wir mit euch gerne tun unter der 0331-77-97-110. Aber vorher glaube ich den einzigen Song über Hubschrauber, den ich gefunden habe. Blockparty und Helikopter. Helikopter, die Blockparty. Ihr hört das Chaos Radio auf Fritz. Mittwochabend Chaos Radio 138 mit Frank Krieger, mit Steini. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranzen. Wir reden über Drohnen und autonom fliegende Objekte. Und am Telefon ist André. Hallo André, guten Abend.
Hallo André, na? Ja, geht gut. Du wolltest was erzählen zum, zum Kongress nämlich an.
Ja, ganz genau. Wie schon letztes Jahr und wie schon auf dem Chaos Camp veranstalten wir auch dieses Jahr wieder einen schönen großen Workshop. Wir werden wieder Live-Zeronen bauen und es wird diesmal eine Flugschule geben. Das heißt auch, Leute, die noch nie geflogen sind, werden ausprobieren können, wie sich so eine Drohne, sein Mikrokopter an der Fernsteuerung anfühlt.
Und wenn sie das Ding abschmieren lassen, was dann?
Dafür haben wir noch einen zweiten Mann, der das abhängen kann.
Das sind die Workshops, von denen Steini gerade sprach, bei der Motodrone?
Also ich hatte letztes auf dem Chaos Camp diesen Workshop organisiert, mit den Mikrokoptern und dieses Jahr, wenn wir das machen, werden wir auf dem Chaos Kongress und werden dann wieder vor der Halle fliegen.
Chaos Communication Kongress, von 27. bis 30. Dezember, vermutlich wieder im Kongresszentrum in Berlin, neben dem Haus des Lehrers am Alexanderplatz.
Eventuell wird es auch wieder Vorträge geben. Es wird ein Entwicklerstreffen geben von dem UAVP-Projekt. Das sind diese Nachfolger von diesen Wolfern-UFOS. Und wie ich so gehört habe, werden noch einige andere Entwickler kommen, um sich da auf dem Kongress damit zu verständigen.
Aber die Entwickler sind schon da. Wir haben ja auch gerade gehört, ein Problem sind eben, das Modellbauer und Entwickler zusammenzukriegen. Wie siehst du das?
Na ja, ich bin eigentlich beides. Ich bin hauptsächlich Modellbauer, weil das mag ich schon seit meinem zehnten Lebensjahr. Und bin aber auch Elektroniker und Programmierer. Und für mich ist das beides nicht das Problem.
Stehst du da in der Modellbauer- und Elektroniker-Szene alleine? Gucken dich die anderen Kollegen komisch an, weil die sagen, du angelst in einem fremden Teich?
Na sagen wir es mal so, wenn ich mit meiner Drohne mal zu meinen anderen Modellsachen mitnehme, die gucken schon komisch, aber die finden es immer cool. Wenn ich damit Filme mache oder Videos aufnehme, dann wollen sie immer alle Videos haben. Und ich soll immer wieder vorbeikommen damit. Das ist schon witzig.
Du kommst auch zum Motodrohnen, hast du gesagt?
Die kommen auch zum Motodrohnen.
Erzähl doch mal, was dein aktueller Stand des Geräts ist. Was kannst du denn mittlerweile?
Ich bin Betatester beim Mikrokopter-Projekt und deswegen habe ich schon relativ wenige in Deutschland GPS drauf. Das heißt, ich kann wirklich auch ein paar Meter genau schweben. Wir können Waypoints fast fliegen. Da warten wir momentan noch auf die neue Software, die Holger und Ingo noch...
Genau, das Navi-Board kommt ja jetzt auch demnächst.
Der große Unterschied zwischen den Drohnen, weil du gerade GPS ansprichst und die normalen Modellflugzeugen ist ja der, dass du im Modellflugzeug stehst und hast einen Kasten mit einer Antenne und steuerst über Funk ein Flugzeug, was nur eine bestimmte Entfernung von dir weg sein oder dran sein muss, damit du überhaupt ein Funknetz da hast. Die Drohne an sich, die kannst du theoretisch starten, setzt dich dann irgendwo in eine Ecke, trinkst Kaffee und das Ding macht genau das, was du ihm programmiert hast und wie Frank schon sagte, die Dinger fliegen bis zu 72 Stunden.
Ja, jetzt nicht diese.
Also die Militärische, die kleinen natürlich nicht.
Die sind noch so groß wie eine 727.
Genau, die von denen, wir reden, die fliegen so eine Viertelstunde, 20 Minuten etwa. Da wird es jetzt demnächst auch einen Schwung nach vorne geben mit neuer Akkutechnologie und mit Sprengstoffzelle. Da kommt jetzt bald was, das bringt uns vermutlich ein Faktor 3, würde ich schätzen. Also eine Stunde wird dann gehen. Irgendwann.
Was ist Faktor 3?
Faktor 3 zu 20 Minuten. Eine Stunde statt 20 Minuten wird, ich würde orakelen, innerhalb der nächsten ein, zwei Jahre machbar sein.
Wie groß ist eigentlich diese Drohnenbauszene, wenn man da von der Szene überhaupt sprechen kann?
Na, bei den Modellbauern ist es mittlerweile recht verbreitet. Ich würde da in Europa locker 200, 300 Leute sehen, die sich da konkret mit beschäftigen und viel mehr, die das halt einfach mal nachgebaut haben, um was gemacht zu haben, um es ausprobiert zu haben. In Deutschland auch bestimmt 50 bis 70 Leute.
Also es sind nicht nur drei Verrückte?
Nee, es sind nicht nur drei Verrückte.
Eine davon ist ja am Telefon. André, du baust ja gerade mal eine Drohne, hast gesagt, du bist Betatester bei Mikrokopter. Was ist denn so die größte Herausforderung im Moment, an der ihr knabbert?
Im Moment ist das Problem, die neuen Parameter zu erfliegen, damit die Regelungstechnik funktioniert.
Also sprich, auf der Stelle zu schweben oder einen Waypoint anzufliegen, ganz konkret, ganz ruhig. Das, was die Micro Drone, das kommerzielle Produkt, eigentlich schon relativ gut oder beeindruckend gut macht, nämlich einfach mal, es steht an einem Punkt und da steht das wie fest genagelt und da kann Wind gehen, das ist völlig egal, das steht da.
Weil es sich permanent korrigiert?
Weil sich das permanent mit aufwendigen Kallmannfiltern und hohen Abtastraten ständig rekalibriert und dann fliegt das, dann sagt man, jetzt fliegst du zu dem Waypoint und dann fliegt das schnurgerade dahin. Das ist beeindruckend gut.
Warum macht man das? Was ist die Herausforderung dabei, außer diesem Daniel-Dysentrieb-Erfindergeist, dass du sagst, ich will wissen, wie es geht?
Naja, wenn du mal, ich sag mal, ein Head-mounted-Display, also ein Fernsehaberat als Brille auf der Nase aufhattest und durch diese Brille gesehen hast, was die Drohne sieht, dann sitzt du plötzlich drin in einem Flugzeug und das geht schon richtig hart in den, du hast nicht das Risiko abzustürzen, aber du fliegst halt wirklich selber Flugzeug. So und du kannst dann, das ist zumindest erst mal die Faszination der Videoübertragung und des Luftbildes und so weiter. Du sitzt halt wirklich drin und für mich die Faszination oder die Motivation autonom fliegende Systeme zu bauen ist, ja hey, das ist ein Roboter, Roboter sind schon immer cool. Also als der Aibo raus kam, das war genau so der Hammer, wie es jetzt fliegende autonome Systeme gibt, wo ich mich über WLAN mit SSH einlogge und sag mal ein Meter höher und mal fünf Meter nach vorne. Das ist schon fett oder ich auf Google Earth oder Google Maps sagen kann, jetzt fliegst du mal nach da, da, da, machst 15 Bilder und kommst zurück.
Okay, da gibt es eine Menge Risiken auch in der Anwendung sowohl technische und auch noch Probleme an den zu knabbern ist, als auch natürlich einige moralische Bedenken beim Stichwort ich baue mir eine selbst fliegende Überwachungskamera und gucke euch dann dabei irgendwie durch Schlüsselloch. Die gibt es jetzt alle hier zu klären im Chaosradio auf Fritz. Wir machen jetzt erstmal die Nachrichten, danach diskutieren wir mit euch weiter. Danke dir André.
Super Radio 3000, wir spielen die größten Super-Mega-Hits aller Zeiten mit der meisten Abwechslung und dem besten von heute im Super-Mega-Mix. Was kann ich für sie tun?
Ja, mein Name ist Jolle vom Interessenverband Deutscher Schrankwandhersteller. Wir haben festgestellt, dass die deutsche Schrankwand ein Image-Problem hat.
Interessant.
Ja, und da dachten wir uns, vielleicht könnten sie ja mal eine Sendung aus einer deutschen Schrankwand senden.
Ja, und da könnten ihre Hörer auch was gewinnen. Zum Beispiel eine Schrankwand.
Interessant.
Ja, und das würden wir uns natürlich auch richtig was kosten lassen.
Interessant, verstehe. Da verbinde ich sie gern mal eben mit unserer Marketing-Abteilung.
An dieser Stelle kommt die Stelle, wo wir mal kurz darauf hinweisen wollen, wie wichtig es ist, dass es Radio- und Fernsehprogramme gibt, die von wirtschaftlichen Interessen und Schrankbandherstellern unabhängig sind und die man für Geld nicht kaufen kann.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit über den Erwerb einer deutschen Schrankwand nachgedacht?
Fritz ist ein öffentlich-rechtliches Radioprogramm und abhängig sind wir auch. Aber nur von euch. Fritz. Powered bei eurer und Funkebühren.
Und das hört man.
Fritz.
Mit Maubatsch. Nach dem Absturz einer Passagiermaschine auf dem Flughafen von Madrid wird die Zahl der Toten immer weiter nach oben korrigiert. Wie die Regionalregierung in Madrid mitteilte, kamen 151 Menschen ums Leben, 20 seien schwer verletzt worden. Ein Sprecher sagte, an Bord der Unglücksmaschine seien 171 Personen gewesen. Herangaben der Fluggesellschaft Lufthansa könnten auch Deutsche unter den Opfern sein. Für den Flug der spanischen Fluggesellschaft Span Air hätten auch vier Deutsche eingecheckt. Die Maschine war unmittelbar nach dem Start in Richtung Gran Canaria zerschellt. Im Georgien-Konflikt verschärft sich der Ton zwischen der Europäischen Union und Russland. Der französische Außenminister und EU-Ratsvorsitzende Kouchner warf Präsident Medvedev Fortbruch vor. Ein größerer Abzug russischer Truppen aus Georgien sei nach wie vor nicht erkennbar. Das sei eine Missachtung internationaler Vereinbarungen, die so nicht hingenommen werden könne, so Kouchner. Medvedev hatte sich vertraglich zum Rückzug der Truppen verpflichtet. Er soll bis Freitagnacht abgeschlossen sein. Bis dahin will die NATO ihre militärische Zusammenarbeit mit Russland ruhen lassen. Die Bundesregierung will die Bürger besser vor Handy-Strahlung schützen. Umweltminister Gabriel kündigte dazu einen Gesetzentwurf an. Die Mobilfunkstrahlung nehme zu, darauf müsse die Politik reagieren, sagten Gabriel und der Präsident des Bundesamtes für Strahlenschutz König bei der Vorstellung des Strahlenschutz-Jahresberichts. Zur Abwehr von Hautkrebs durch künstliche UV-Strahlen bekräftigte Gabriel die Absicht, Minderjährigen und Jugendlichen den Besuch von Sonnenstudios zu verbieten. Beide Vorhaben sollen in das neue Umweltgesetzbuch aufgenommen werden.
60 Rettungswagen und Zahl reicht.
Start! Die deutsche Fußballnationalmannschaft spielt heute Abend in Nürnberg gegen Belgien ihr erstes Testspiel nach der Europameisterschaft. Eine Viertelstunde vor Schluss steht es 1 zu 0 nach einem Pfahlelfmetertor durch Bastian Schweinsteiger. Heute Nacht ist es meist trocken bei Tiefstwerten bis 12 Grad. Am Tag dann ein Wechsel aus Sonne und Wolken, dabei nur selten kurze Schauer. Die Höchstwerte liegen bei 25 Grad. A13 Dresden Richtung Berlin. Zwischen dem Übergang Landesgrenze und Ortrand liegen Gegenstände, nämlich ein großes Teil auf der linken Spur. B167 Löwenberg Richtung Lebus. Zwischen Hohenfino und Kreuzung Bad Freienwalde in beiden Richtungen Gefahr durch Tiere auf der Fahrbahn da besonders vorsichtig. Im Kreis Stendal ebenfalls Gefahr durch Tiere auf der Fahrbahn zwischen Schönfeld und Wulkao auf der B107 in Richtung Havelberg. Und Stadtverkehr Berlin A100 Stadtring Richtung Wedding. Am Tempelhofer Damm ist die Ausfahrt gesperrt, dort wird gebaut, es gibt aber eine Umleitung. Sonst überall gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 102, 6 dann Fritz in Berlin.
Mittwoch Abend Chaosradiozeit 138. Frank-Riorn Steini sind hier. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Wir wollen mit euch und uns und allen anderen über autonome Fluggeräte, also Drohnen, reden. Wir haben uns gerade schon so ein bisschen erwähnt, wo die Dinger herkommen, wer die so verwendet, wozu braucht man eigentlich Drohnen?
Also für die momentanen Anwendungsfälle außerhalb des Militärs gibt es halt relativ wenige. Es gibt immer wieder so Versuche, wo sowas von der Polizei eingesetzt wird für Stadien oder auch gelegentlich von der Feuerwehr, für Großlagen, um einen Überblick zu gewinnen. Architekten verwenden es gerne für Luftbilder.
Gegenden, wo du einfach von oben mal die Lage checken musst.
Genau, billig Luftbilder machen schnell, ohne dass du irgendwie noch ein Flugzeug mit einem Flugplan und so weiter und so fort brauchst, momentan die Hauptanwendung. Der Idealfall, wie er doch beim Militär verwendet wird, ist Rucksack auf Drohne raus, hoch damit und hast dann in den 5 Minuten live auf dem Boden und wenn irgendwas ist, kannst du hinfliegen und gucken.
Oder halt billig. Ohne einen Hubschrauber und ein Flugzeug bemühen zu müssen, mal von der Großbaustelle ein Überblickbild für den Chef machen.
Genau.
Wir haben gerade erwähnt, dass es die Dinger als Bausatz auch zu kaufen gibt, also die quasi zivile Variante, die er ja gerade auch testet. Kann ich mich theoretisch an jeder Ecke der Stadt hinsetzen, kann so ein Ding auspacken, kann meine Drohne fliegen lassen oder kommt da irgendjemand und sagt, so geht es aber nicht?
Also die Rechtslage ist relativ eindeutig, weil technisch gesehen geht so eine Drohne als Modellflugzeug, also eine Selbstbordrohne, die sind halt klein und leicht. Das heißt also, wenn du die in bewohnten Gegenden fliegen willst, musst du halt irgendwie alle Handauflagen erfüllen. Also darfst nicht eine bestimmte Höhe überschreiten, insbesondere statt nicht wo Luftverkehr ist. Also Berlin ist ja komplett Kontrolle der Luftraum. Also musst das Ding immer so fliegen, dass du es noch siehst. So zum Beispiel auch ein Mikrokopter mit einem Navigationsbord drauf, also der halt GPS hat, wird halt nicht weiter fliegen, als deine Funkvermindung reicht, weil das darf er nicht. Also das ist halt rechtlich, das Ding ist halt ein Modellflugzeug. Das heißt, es muss noch in den Bereich sein, wo du uns zweifel mit der Vermindung eingreifen kannst.
Und es braucht eine Versicherung, eine Modellhaftpflichtversicherung. Fliege niemals ohne Modellhaftpflichtversicherung.
Das kann relativ schnell relativ teuer werden. Also wenn das Ding zum Beispiel auf eine Strache kracht, der LKW-Fahrer geht vor Schreck auf die Bremsen, auf Fahrunfall.
Szenario ist jedem selbst überlassen, wie es dann am Ende ausgeht. Okay, aber das heißt, dass dieses Szenario, was wir am Anfang ja auch beschrieben haben, jeder baut sich eine Drohne und guckt dann dem Nachbarn irgendwie in den Garten oder durch das Badezimmer-Winster, in dem Fall dann auch nicht zutrifft, weil du darfst die Dinger an der Stadt ja gar nicht fliegen.
Na gut, aber auf dem Land darfst du sie zum Beispiel schon fliegen. Also wenn du halt außer kontrolliert in den Luftraum bist, ist es kein Problem. Außerdem ist es halt so, dass es effektiv nicht zu kontrollieren ist.
Ja, zwischen nicht dürfen und nicht machen.
Also die Dinger haben halt kein Nummernschild, die sagen halt nicht, ich gehöre xy. Und wenn so ein Ding halt neben dir die Straße runterfliegt, da gibt es keine Ahnung, wem das gehört. Also da gibt es halt schon noch ein bisschen wilder Westen an der Ecke. Und andere Anwendungsfälle sind auch Filmproduktionen, die halt normalerweise sich einen Hubschrauber mieten würden, um zum Beispiel halt irgendwie den Flug durch die Straßenschlucht zu machen. Kannst du auch mit einer Drohne machen, ist viel billiger, mietest du dir halt so eine Drohne. Also da gibt es halt schon eine Menge Anwendungsfälle. In den allermeisten Fällen sind es halt Durchbilder. Es gibt halt auch andere Anwendungsfälle, die jetzt so ausprobiert werden, halt so gerade so in dem Gebiet Notfallrettung zum Beispiel, um einen Sensor in die Qualmwolke zu fliegen, um zu gucken, wie giftig ist der Scheiß denn gerade, der da verbrennt. Das ist halt so ein Anwendungsfall, den die Feuerwehr gerne haben möchte, dass sie halt Proben direkt aus der Rauchwolke entnehmen kann oder direkt analysieren können und übertragen bekommen kann, was das Problem ist. Dann gibt es Anwendungsfälle zum Beispiel in größeren übersichtlichen Katastrophen halt Menschen zu finden, so was weiß ich, Erdbeben, Verschüttungsgebiete, dergleichen Dinge mehr. Also da gibt es halt eine große Reihe von, sagen wir mal, sinnvollen und zivilen Anwendungsfällen, genauso wie es halt eine große Reihe von eben, naja, militärischen, nicht so sinnvollen Anwendungsfällen gibt, die man halt eigentlich nicht möchte.
Sind die Dinger denn im zivilen Bereich überhaupt schon im Einsatz?
Ja, also gerade bei Architekten und Bauherren und so. Es gibt in Berlin schon mehrere Unternehmen, die diese Dienstleistung mit Drohnen anbieten, Luftbilder machen zu können. Es ist auch in der Forschung auf ganz anderen Gebiet im Einsatz, um nicht immer nur über die Quadrokopter zu reden, sondern auch Drohnen in Form von Modellflugzeugen, die den Vorteil haben, dass sie nicht permanent Energie aufwenden müssen, um oben zu bleiben. Durch die Tragflächen ist der Energieaufwand geringer. Die fliegen dann auch länger und vor allem weiter. Da ist sicherlich zu nennen das Paparazzi-Projekt, das auch auf der Motodrone anwesend sein wird, Vorführungen machen wird, einen Vortrag halten wird. Die haben im Prinzip Autopiloten für Modellflugzeuge entwickelt, was den Vorteil hat, dass man damit eben mal sehr schnell, sehr hoch fliegen kann, um damit zum Beispiel für Geologen, Geografen und so weiter als Werkzeug zu dienen, eben wieder für Luftbilder. Die haben in Alaska einen Versuch gemacht. Da haben sie mal geguckt, wie hoch sie kommen. Bei drei Kilometern nach fünf Minuten haben sie dann abgebrochen. Das sieht man dann auch nicht mehr. Und man sieht nur noch von oben das Bild. Alles wird immer kleiner unten in dem Weiten. Das ist schon unheimlich. Das haben sie dann mal wieder runterkommen lassen, das Gerät.
Es gibt auch schon seit mehreren Jahren diese amerikanische Firma, die baut Starflügel, also große Modellflugzeuge. Die sind über den Atlantik geflogen, und zwar mehrfach. Die sind halt von Neuf-Hundernd nach Urland zurück geflogen. Modellflugzeug. Die Modellflugzeuge sind ein bisschen größer, haben einen Verbrennungsmotor wegen der Energiedichte und haben damit meteorologische Forschung gemacht. Die können damit einfach mal quer durch das Wetter durchfliegen, weil du sonst halt ein Wetterflugzeug brauchst. Und das können sie halt mit vielen Flugzeugen für verdammt wenig Geld machen.
Womit wir gleich nochmal beim Begriff Drohne sind. Drohne heißt, das sind ja die männlichen Bienen, ich hatte das damals auch schon mal angerissen. Da gibt es viele von und sie dienen genau einem einzigen Zweck und sie sind billig. Das ist der Zweck der Drohne, wenn ein Mensch zu wertvoll ist und das ja unter militärischen Maßstäben ist, das ja nicht das Menschenleben, das da was zählt, sondern die Kosten für die Ausbildung. Wenn ein Mensch also zu wertvoll ist, dann schickt man eine Drohne. Das ist genau der Aspekt. Wenn die billig genug sind, kann ich ganz viele schicken und dann ist mir egal, ob 70% oder 80% oder 95% verschwinden, solange die 5% zurückkommen und die gewünschte Information liefern.
Okay, das sind jetzt aber alles Aspekte, wo man sagen könnte, super, prima, toll, hurra, sollten wir jetzt flächendeckend einführen, weil alle können die gebrauchen. Ihr habt ja gerade gesagt, von Katastrophenschutz über Feuerwehrwärme hinzu. Tausend verschiedene Einsatzmöglichkeiten, da gibt es wahrscheinlich alle 5 Minuten, je länger man drüber nachdenkt, noch mehr. Da gibt es jetzt aber auch die Gegenseite. Zum einen führt das zu der Vision, dass irgendwie die Stadt und alles andere von irgendwelchen Drohnen bevölkert ist, weil man die Dinge selber bauen kann und weil ich jetzt auf die Idee komme, irgendwie meine komplette Straße und meine Stadt zu überwachen. Vielleicht komme ich auch nicht auf die Idee, sondern der Bürgermeister meiner Stadt oder der Chef meines Landes oder der Chef meiner Regierung oder wer auch immer, der da quasi flächendeckende Überwachung mit den Dingern treibt, da gibt es ja nicht nur diesen einen Aspekt, den man durchaus kritisch betrachten könnte.
Ja, also das Hauptproblem ist, dass im militärischen Bereich zum Beispiel verschwindet halt die Grenze zwischen Realität und Computerspiel. Also wenn so ein Drohenoperator da sitzt, für den sieht es halt der Simulator genau gleich aus, wie das Bild, was er von einer Drohne kriegt. Also der kann das halt einfach nicht mehr unterscheiden. Der hat halt keinerlei, der sitzt da nicht mehr drin. Das heißt, der fliegt den Flugsimulator, nur dass am Ende von dem Flugsimulator hängt tatsächlich eine Drohne dran.
Womöglich sieht er nicht mal das Kamerabild.
Genau, und das Ding hat halt Raketen drunter. Und der kann halt diese Raketen abschießen auf ein Ziel, was er auf seinem Bildschirm anklickt. Das heißt also, der ist völlig entkoppelt von der tatsächlichen Handlung, die er vornimmt. Und genau dasselbe kann auch im zivilen Bereich passieren. Also gerade im polizeilichen Bereich zum Beispiel, oder auch im privaten Sicherheitsbereich, gibt es nun schon die ersten Wachschutzroboter. Also Dinger, die halt durch die Gegend rollen und irgendwie sagen, da haben wir nichts zu suchen, was wollen Sie hier? In Berlin gibt es eine Firma, die Robo Watch heißen die. Die haben jetzt gerade an die Chinesen eine große Staffel von den Dingern geliefert. Die kurren jetzt in den chinesischen Stadien rum. Und das ist natürlich erst der Anfang der Entwicklung. Das ist halt ein weites Feld, wie man so schön sagt. Und da ist dann halt die Frage, gerade durch diese Entkopplung zwischen der eigentlichen Handlung, also dem, was in der realen Welt passiert, und der Steuerung durch den Menschen oder auch nur der Beobachtung dessen, was der Roboter tut durch den Menschen, sinken halt die Hemmschwellen. Wenn ich halt nur auf den Knopf drücken muss und dann saut ich der Roboter mit Pfefferspray ein, der vor dir steht, ist das was komplett anderes, als wenn ich das selber tun muss und die Schreien hören muss und sehen muss, wie du die Augen kratzt.
Ja klar, aber in dem Moment, ob es jetzt der Sicherheitsroboter ist oder was auch immer, weil natürlich die Maschine in einem normalen Programmablauf folgt und irgendwie genau das tut, was man ihr vorher gesagt hat, während eine menschliche Einsatzkraft, sage ich jetzt mal, natürlich immer auch die Situation hat, dass sie abschätzen kann, wie muss ich in der Situation reagieren, kann ich das jetzt in irgendeiner Form beeinflussen, kann ich es abwenden.
Hat einen moralischen Handlungsspielraum.
So heißt das schon.
Genau. Und den hat ein Roboter nicht, auch einen ferngesteuert, der Roboter hat davon viel weniger. Der Weg dahin sind jetzt Versuche bei den Soldaten mit dem Gewehr in der Hand übers Feld, Robben, Zielen, aber Abdrücken tut über Funk jemand anderes, dann sind die nicht schuld. Und der, der abgedrückt hat, ist irgendwie auch nicht schuld. Aber das senkt auch die Hemmschwelle. Noch besser wird es natürlich, wenn da kein Mensch mehr durchs Gemüse kraucht, sondern halt irgendeine Maschine da langfährt und auf der anderen Seite sitzt, es gibt ja diverse Science-Fiction-Stories und Filme zum Thema, sitzen irgendwelche 15-jährigen Jungs, die das halt besonders gut beherrschen, weil deren Reflexe noch richtig gut sind und die ballern da munter drauf los und knallen halt die Gegner weg, dass es nur so Punkte regnet. Und kriegen dann Highscore, wenn sie da top sind. Ohne zu wissen, was sie tun.
Gibt es denn da irgendwie, okay, das wäre jetzt die militärische Variante, gibt es denn für den zivilen Einsatz da in irgendeiner Form schon eine rechtliche Grundlage, ein rechtliches Netz, irgendwas, worauf man sich berufen kann?
Momentan ist das alles sehr unterentwickelt.
Goldgräber Nuggets City.
Ja, also momentan ist es so, dass die Technologie halt noch so am Rande von dem ist, was geht. Also diese Wachschutzroboter z.B. litten halt primär darunter, dass sie bei den ersten Einsätzen einfach weggetragen wurden. Da kamen halt so ein paar Türken-Kits und meinten, oh cool, sieht teuer aus, nehmen wir mal mit. So, war noch teuer. So haben wir erstmal eingesackt. Jetzt haben sie halt einfach ordentlich Blei und Akkus reingemacht, jetzt kann man die nicht mehr so einfach weg tragen. Aber die Technologie wird jetzt langsam benutzbar und die wird jetzt tatsächlich auch angewendet im realen zivilen Leben. So und bei den fliegenden Drohnen, um dahin nochmal zurückzugehen, ist es so, dass es schon sehr problematisch ist, weil die eigentlich die Luftraumbestimmungen das nicht vorsehen. Also du hast normalerweise, wenn du da irgendetwas rumfliegen willst, musst du einen Flugplan einreichen. Und dieser Flugplan sagt halt, wo du von wann nach wo fliegst, wegen du möglicherweise ins Gehebe kommen kannst und so weiter. Du musst halt eingeplant werden, wo der Operator zu erreichen ist.
Ich bin Hubschrauber und da fliegt eine Drohne vor mir lang und die fliegt bei mir im Weg rum. Genau, was machst du dann? Wenn das Ding aber autonom fliegt und der Programmierer sitzt irgendwo anders hinter seinem Bildschirm, kriegst du ja das gar nicht mit.
Genau, das ist halt so ein Problem. Deswegen werden Drohnen momentan vorwiegend unter militärischen Luftraumregeln geflogen. Da können die halt beliebige Ausnahmen deklarieren, sagen, hier ist mal militärischer Luftraum, hier machen wir was wir wollen. Die Polizei fliegt die Dinge, zumindest in Deutschland, nach, wir fliegen hier einen Polizeihubschrauber rum, deklarieren den Luftraum als passen sie auf, wenn sie hier lang fliegen. Oder hier dürfen sie nicht lang fliegen, sie sperren den Luftraum und fliegen da halt rum. Was jetzt die Architekten machen, die so Luftbilder machen, ich glaube, die kümmern sich schon.
Die scheren sich einen Scheiß.
Die fliegen halt auch nicht so hoch. Kritisch wird es halt am 300 Meter, weil dann bist du halt wirklich im Luftraum.
Also die Architekten sind eher die Alternative. Es gibt so Services, die kommen dann mit so einem kleinen Hubkran und machen dann aus 20 Metern Höhe ein Bild. Die Bilder wären ja auch nicht mehr toll, wenn du zu hoch fliegst. Aber machen wir uns nichts vor. Die scheren sich da einen Dreck drum und die fliegen auch mal 300, 400 Meter hoch, wenn das Bild dann besser wird. Letztlich muss man auch überlegen, so richtig tragisch ist es nicht, das Ding wiegt mit allem 600, 700 Gramm. So eine Ente wiegt locker mal 5 Kilo. Das muss ein Flieger auch abkönnen.
Die kleinen Drohnen sind halt noch nicht ein richtiges Problem. Da gewinnt das Flugzeug. Deswegen gibt es halt auch diese Gewichtsbeschränkungen. Bis 3 Kilo ist es halt ein Modellflugzeug.
Dann ist es ein Sportgerät.
Darüber wird es halt kritisch. 3 Kilo ist glaube ich die Grenze, wo man sagen kann, gibt es halt ein Dudu mit einem Zweigefinger und vielleicht eine Geldstrafe. Darüber ist es dann Verstoß gegen Luftfahrtrechten.
Das ist jetzt sozusagen die Grundlage für diese Goldgräberstimmung. Deswegen lasst es immer ein Ding bauen, was autonom fliegen kann.
Diese Goldgräberstimmung gibt es natürlich auch noch in einem sehr viel breiteren Raum. Wiederum natürlich getrieben von Mediziner. Da gibt es halt diverse Dutzend Firmen weltweit, die halt so eine Dinge bauen. Also angefangen von Fallschirmen, die selber wissen, wo sie hinfliegen müssen. Also kriegst du Dinge einfach mit einer einprogrammierten GPS-Adress aus dem Flugzeug raus und der hat halt einen steuerbaren Fallschirm und fliegt die halbe Tonne Last, die da drunter hängt, mit diesem Fallschirm, ohne dass da ein menschlicher Hit im Wege ist, dahin, wo es soll.
Und du den Anhänger da nicht aus dem See ziehen musst.
Genau, so eine Sache. Also da gibt es halt eine Menge Entwicklungen. Es gibt halt, wie gesagt, meteorische Beobachtungsdrohnen noch in Nöcher, in allen großen Farben und Formen. Da werden Raketen drunter geschnallt. Wie gesagt, bei der Polizei ist es halt so, die großen Drohnen werden mittlerweile auch verwendet. Also zum Beispiel hat die Polizei Amsteln eine große israelische Drohne gekauft. Die haben aber genau eben dieses Problem, dass sie nicht wissen, wie sie die großen Dinge problemlos in den Luftraum integriert behandelt.
Was heißt eine große Drohne? Wie groß ist denn so ein Ding dann?
Also die Kleinen hast du gerade gesagt, steinig sind sie irgendwie 700 Gramm und vielleicht so groß wie ein Stück Papier, ein A4-Blatt oder so.
Na, ein bisschen größer sind sie schon, aber A3.
Also so eine große Drohne kann halt locker mal irgendwas zwischen 50 und 200 Kilo wiegen und halt schon richtig so 2, 50 Meter Spannweite haben und dann auch gerne mal 6 Stunden Luft bleiben.
Also wir reden hier sowas über so PKW-Größe.
Genau, und die gibt es halt dann bis so irgendwie 7,2,7 Größe. Das sind halt dann die richtig großen.
So was fliegt man natürlich nicht einfach so durch die Stadt.
Ne, dafür muss man sich dann schon was ausdenken. Und wie man diese Luftfahrtregeln irgendwie in Einklang bringt, ob man jetzt zum Beispiel ein Funkgerät in die Drohne einbaut, was dann das Funksignal zum Operator zurückschieht, damit er wach wird, oder ob man dem Tower eine Möglichkeit gibt, auf den Knopf zu drücken, dass die Drohne erst mal da bleibt, wo sie ist, und eine Warteschleife fliegt. Und dergleichen Dinge mehr. Da gibt es halt lange und dreckige Diskussionen so in diesen Luftfahrtregeln.
Bisher ist, glaube ich, Praxis, dass ein Operator jederzeit Sichtkontakt haben können muss und jederzeit eingreifen können muss. Auch bei den Challenges und so ist das immer Bedingung.
Wenn ihr die, wir können es ja gerne nochmal sagen, Motodrone macht.
Das sind die Modellbauregeln halt. Also wenn man nach Modellbauregeln fliegt, heißt es Sichtkontakt und jeder Operator muss eingreifen können. Und die Software ist halt auch so beschaffen, dass sie das enforce. Aber wie gesagt, gerade bei den großen Drohnen, zum Beispiel für polizeilichen Einsatz oder auch zum Beispiel für Katografierungen in der Landwirtschaft, das ist auch so ein Thema, wo gerne versucht wird, sowas einzusetzen. Die sind dann halt schon richtig so groß wie ein kleines Flugzeug und mit entsprechendem Chancepotenzial. Also da muss man sich halt schon echt was überlegen.
Also wenn die irgendwo runterkommen oder im Weg stehen...
Dann ist das als wenn so ein Chessner runterfällt. Also deshalb so dieselbe Größenklasse.
Aber ist nicht diese Regulierung von wegen der Operator muss immer in der Nähe der Drohne sein? Beißt sich das nicht so ein bisschen mit dem Gedanken, die Dinger sind autonom?
Na klar. Es wird komplizierter. Es wird noch viel komplizierter. Es beißt sich ja nicht nur an dieser Stelle Drohnen. Naja, das können ja auch andere Dinge sein, um da mal das Augenmerk drauf zu lenken. Alle reden über selbstfahrende Autos, in denen ich nur noch drin sitze.
Da gibt es ja auch regelmäßige Veranstaltungen, wo sowas ganz genau...
Technisch sind wir da auch schon sehr weit. Wir sind mittlerweile auch bei selbstfahrenden U-Bahnen. Da ist jetzt die erste im Regelbetrieb genommen worden. Genau genommen ist das eine Drohne. Da fährt eine Maschine von A nach B. Da sitzt keiner mehr drin, der das Ding steuert und auch keiner, der jetzt nach vorne rausguckt und auf die Bremse haut, wenn was komisch ist. So, da sitzt ein Computer und da sitzt irgendwo in der Zentrale ein Kaffeedrinkender Operator mit den Füßen auf den Tisch und reagiert garantiert zu spät. Und damit müssen wir uns jetzt beschäftigen. Was passiert denn, wenn so ein Ding einen Unfall baut? Wer ist denn dann schuld? Hat jetzt der Programmierer Scheiß gebaut, braucht gerne Versicherung, hat jetzt vielleicht die Firma, die das Ding vertreibt, ein Siemens oder wer auch immer, den schuld, hat vielleicht irgendwie der Betreiber der Straßenbahnschuld, hat der Mensch schuld, der sich reingesetzt hat und schön blöd war.
Da gibt es auch noch keine Regulierung dafür.
Das ist ein Thema, wo wir uns jetzt ein bisschen beschäftigen, zu überlegen, wie können solche Regeln aussehen. Weil das Problem ist, wir wissen halt, dass es keine fehlerfreie Software gibt. Und wir wissen, dass das Missbrauch potenzial hoch ist, eben dadurch, dass da halt kein Mensch mehr drin sitzt. Also du kannst halt einen Roboter bauen, da hängt nach bisher so schwierigen Regeln nicht mal ein Nummernschild dran.
Aber im Zweifelsfall eine Kiste Dynamit.
Wenn du es so übertreiben möchtest, hängt da eine Kiste Dynamit dran.
Ich dachte mal, ich übertreibe das jetzt mal so, um das Problem zu skizzieren.
Und das heißt, es gibt da momentan keine Regeln, keine Regularien. Und vermutlich wird man irgendein Mittelding finden müssen wie für Autos, also Haftpflicht plus Kennzeichen plus Besitzer bekannt. Und ein TÜV, damit klar ist, dass das Ding zumindest bremsenhaft auf die Bremse tritt. Also irgendeine Art von Regelwerk wird sich da wohl entwickeln lassen müssen.
Aber im Moment ist doch die technische Entwicklung wesentlich schneller als das, was auf der gesetzlichen Seite passiert.
Nein, wir sind noch relativ früh. Also es ist schon so, dass der, wenn man sich so anguckt, was jetzt für bodenbewegte Fahrzeuge am weitesten vorne ist, ist halt diese DARPA-Challenge. Die findet alle zwei Jahre statt. Die Defense Advanced Research Program Agency in den USA. Das ist so der Science-Fiction-Kann-auch-heute-gehen-Sync-Tank. Die geben halt Geld dafür aus, Technologie sehr weit zu entwickeln. Zu sagen, können wir heute schon ein Auto durch eine Stadt fahren? Autonomen. Etwa als die DARPA-Challenge letztes Jahr. Und man kann. Also die letzte DARPA-Challenge hat gezeigt, man kann ein Auto irgendwie 35 Kilometer durch eine von Fahrzeugen und Fußgängern belebte Stadt fahren.
Ohne dass irgendeine Katze oder ein Hydrant danach Schaden genommen hat.
Also der Sieger kam durch. Also ein paar andere sind halt natürlich gegen die Wand gefahren oder in andere Autos gefahren und so weiter. Aber im Prinzip ist es halt standard Technik. Die Autos sind halt mit Sensoren voll gefrofft bis zum Abwinken. Und mit Computertechnik aber funktioniert. Bei den Autoverstellern ist es halt so, dass die halt schon so ein bisschen zögerlich sind, selbstfahrende Autos zu bauen. Die haben halt genau dieses Haftpflichtproblem auch erkannt. Die müssen halt irgendwie regeln, wer da schuld ist.
Und deswegen gibt es die Großteilentwicklung eben im Luftbereich, weil wie du am Anfang gesagt hast, Frank, da gibt es einfach wesentlich weniger Hindernisse, auf die man achten muss. Eher wo man reinfallen oder dagegen fahren kann. Ihr könnt gerne mit uns diskutieren. Wir haben jetzt Chaosradio auf Fritz. Wir reden über unbemannte und autonome Fluggeräte bzw. Fahrzeuge. Wir haben es ja gerade auch bei den Autos hatten. Wir reden über Drohnen, was da gerade so technisch möglich ist und natürlich auch die Motodrone, die am 20.9. in Niederfino stattfindet. Ihr könnt anrufen. 0331 70 97 110 und nach der Technik Goro Schlechner anrufen. Nämlich Axel. Hallo Axel, guten Abend. Das ist doch eigentlich genau dein Thema, oder?
Genau, aber wie? Also pass auf, das Problem, was ihr eben sagtet, mit den Versicherungsproblemen, wer hat denn da das Problem? Das hatten wir doch jetzt schon. Wenn wir von dem Airbus-Unfall, wann war der? A 92, A 93 in Warschau. Es ging A 320, setzt auf die Bahn auf und der Rechner sagt, wegen des Aquaplanings, Flugzeug ist nicht gelandet, es wird nicht gebremst.
Moment, das Flugzeug ist gelandet, Wasser auf der Landebahn?
Ich will die Geschichte länger erzählen. Sturm und Regen in Warschau, eine Lufthansa A 320, würde ich denken, fliegt dorthin, landet, Landebahn steht relativ tief unter Wasser, ein, zwei Zentimeter, was sehr viel ist, für das normale Profil eines Flugzeugreifens, weil das ist hier mehr ein Flick, und aufgrund eines Messfehlers, oder besser gesagt eines falscheingestellten Grenzwertes, beschließt der Bordrechner, das Flugzeug hat noch nicht aufgesetzt, die Bremsen werden noch nicht ausgelöst, um zu verhindern, normalerweise ist die Idee richtig, dass das Flugzeug mit angezogenen Bremsen landet.
Da muss ich kurz korrigieren. Die Räder drehten sich nicht, weil die Bremse griff und dadurch, die durch Aquaplaning ins Rutschen kamen, die Maschine, dann aber der Computer nicht akzeptiert, dass die Maschine am Boden ist, weil die Erkennung dafür, dass die Maschine am Boden ist, ist das Drehen der Räder und nur dann kann man Gegenschub einschalten.
Meiner Ansicht nach war das Problem, dass der Landedrucksensor auf 15 Tonnen eingestellt ist.
Ich würde sagen, speziellen Details bei diesem...
Wir einigen uns darauf, es war ein Software-Problem.
Es war ein Software-Problem. Erinner uns bitte darauf. Es war ein Software-Problem und das Software-Problem war eindeutig, der Pilot war an Bord, er konnte aber nichts tun.
Er konnte nicht bremsen, er konnte Gegenschub nicht einhassen.
Er konnte weder den Reverser fahren, noch konnte er bremsen. Da haben wir im Prinzip schon genau das, wie du eben sagst, mit der U-Mann, der Kollege tritt zu spät auf die Bremse, wenn er sieht. Der hat zum richtigen Zeitpunkt auf die Bremse getreten, er konnte aber einfach nicht. Also ist das Problem ja schon dahin verlagert. Ja, wir hatten jetzt das Problem, hat das Airbus, hat das der Softwarehersteller, hat das die Lufthansa, hat das der Flughafenverlag, hat das der Pilot, weil er ja vielleicht irgendwas hätte erinnern können. Nein, stand im Nachhinein fast, er hätte an der Stelle gar nichts machen können. Ja, also denke ich, ganz neu ist das Problem eigentlich.
Aber es gibt ja keine gute Lösung dafür. Also bei dem Airbus-Verwahrter am Ende so, dass Airbus im Sorry gesagt hat und sich an den... Und hat sich halt an den Scharnersatzzahlen beteiligt, aber das war es halt im Wesentlichen so. Also interessant ist halt, dass es da momentan kein gutes Haftungsrecht für Software gibt. So und damit kommen wir zum Kern einer Sache, weil wir haben da Software, die nicht mehr Texte verarbeitet und irgendwie deinen Text verschwinden lässt, wo da halt irgendwie auch niemand findet, der dafür haftbar ist, sondern man hat Software, die halt für den Schädel einschlägt. So und bei Industrierobotern wird das halt so gelöst, dass gesagt wird, okay, es handelt sich um eine Gefahrenzone. Wenn das Ding loslegt, dann bist du bitte da weg. Also ich hab auch mal Industrieroboter programmiert, das ist halt eine sehr weise Angelegenheit. Also ich hab als erstes irgendwie die Abdeckscheibe von so einer Drehmaschine zertrümmert, weil die war halt noch im Weg.
Und ganz konkret gibt es da aber auch schon echte Rechtsfälle, bei der Roboter Schaden verursacht haben, nämlich dort, wo sich genau das nicht vermeiden lässt, wo es nämlich genau darum geht, dass Roboter was an Menschen machen, nämlich in der Medizin. Da weiß Frank noch eine schöne Geschichte zu.
Da fällt mir noch was ein, dieser Bestrahlungsgeschichte von der kanadischen Firma, die aufgrund eines Softwarefehlers das Strahltarget nicht in Strahl gefahren hat. Und man damit also irgendwie...
Moment, Axel, was für ein Strahltarget? Kannst du ganz kurz erzählen?
Also eine kanadische Firma hat ein medizinisches Bestrahlungsgerät gebaut, das zwei Betriebsmodi hatte. Es hatte ein Betriebsmodus Röntgenbestrahlung. Zu diesem Zwecke wurde der Positron- oder Elektronenbeschleuniger in einem relativ hohen Energiemodus gefahren. Die Elektronen schlugen auf ein Target, auf ein Ziel auf, ein Wolfram-Target oder irgendwie sowas. Und dieses Wolfram-Target emittierte dann Röntgenstrahlen. Das ist der eine Betriebsmodus. Der andere Betriebsmodus war, dass die Elektronen direkt auf den menschlichen Körper appliziert werden sollten. Damit war aber die Beschleuniger-Energie wesentlich geringer. Und nun kam es zu der sehr ungünstigen Verknüpfung der Möglichkeit, dass, obwohl das Bremsstrahl-Target, sprich dieser Wolfram-Körper nicht im Strahl war, der Beschleuniger auf den hohen Beschleunigungsmodus umschalten konnte. Bei Fehleingaben und Softwarefehlverarbeitung. Da hat man lange auseinandergenommen, es gab zwei mögliche Fehler an der Stelle. Und da hat man richtig Leute um die Ecke gebracht. Hat man wegen falscher Einstellungen Leute richtig um die Ecke gebracht.
Und da sehen wir auch gerade, wie gefährlich diese graue Zone ist, wo schon jetzt nicht unbedingt Softwarefehler, sondern Bedienfehler schon zu ernstlichen Problemen. Also Bedienfehler komplexer technischer Geräte. In den meisten technischen Geräten sind ja heute Mikrocontroller mit Software drin. Machen wir uns nichts vor, selbst in deinem Radiowecker. Es gibt ja fast kein Gerät mehr in deinem Kühlschrank, überall ist ein Mikrocontroller drin. Da ist dann Software drin. Und diese Software, da kannst du mitunter gar nicht mehr jeden Zustand, den das System erreichen kann, vorher testen und simulieren. Das ist mitunter nicht deterministisch, wenn das auf Basis von Sensor-Input funktioniert. Da kann sonst was passieren unter bizarren besonderen Umständen. Solche Bedienfehler oder eben solche Probleme führen dann auch bei Systemen, die an sich menschlich bedient sind, zu katastrophalen Fehlern.
Um zum eigentlichen Thema zurückzukommen, von den Wolfram-Elektronen und irgendwelchen Flugzeugen und so, wir waren ja eigentlich bei autonom sich bewegenden Geräten, bei Drohnen. Um mal wieder zum eigentlichen Thema zurückzukommen, gibt es da, oder in dieser Roboterwelt, gibt es da schon Fälle, wo es in irgendeiner Art von Rechtsprechung gab?
Also es gab halt diesen Fall, den Steini gerade angesprochen hat. Diese RoboDoc-Systeme waren halt automatische Hüftgelenk, Operationsroboter, wo Leute hinterher einfach massive Schäden hatten, weil da offensichtlich entweder ein Software-Bug gab oder ein Hardware-Fehler, das war mir jetzt nicht mehr so ganz klar. Und die haben halt erstmal Recht bekommen. Also zwar aber einfache Produkthaftung. Also sie haben, so wurde gesagt, es handelte sich um eine defekte, kaputte medizinische Hardware, die ihnen das Leben versaut hat. Und dafür haben sie halt irgendwie Schande dazu gesprochen bekommen. Und da wurden halt aber interessante Fragen nicht geklärt. Also ist jetzt halt der Betreiber mehr zuständig oder mehr der Hersteller. Das haben sie dann halt irgendwie mit großen Schandersatzzahlungen gelöst. Aber solche komplexen Technikfälle treten halt immer wieder aus. Auch zum Beispiel bei Industrieanlagen. Also Industrieanlagen gehen häufiger als man denkt durch Softwareprobleme kaputt. Da fährt dann halt irgendwie irgendein Prozessparameter hoch oder ein Sensor geht fritte und wird nicht richtig ausgelesen.
Und irgendein autonom fahrender Gabelstapler. Und davon gibt es mittlerweile richtig, richtig, richtig viele Krachtanhalte ins Hochregallager und die ganze Geschichte puttelt zusammen.
Im günstigsten Fall stehst du einfach an 50 Liter Frittierfett. Aber ihr seht schon, die Problematik ist relativ komplex und noch nicht mal im Ansatz irgendwie durchdacht. Deswegen machen wir auch diese Sendung hier, das Chaosradio, um mal so ein bisschen auf dieses Thema hinzuweisen. Und im Zweifelsfall könnt ihr euch auch gerne am 20.9. nach Niederfino bewegen. Dafür nehme ich die Motodrone. Fino-Ford. Niederfino ist auf der anderen Seite.
Auf dem alten Militärflugplatz.
Klar, eine Drohne muss man auf dem Flugplatz fliegen lassen.
Ja klar, logisch.
Ich würde wetten, dass Axel dann auch da sein wird.
Unter www.motodrohnen.de kann man sich da auch nochmal alle Informationen abholen.
Danke Axel.
Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Chaosradio 138 mit Frank Rieger, mit Steini, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, wir reden über Drohnen. Wir haben jetzt eine Menge geredet, lass uns kurz ein bisschen Musik hören, oder? Die Vos aus England, Olympic Airways, Chaosradio 138, kurz nach 11, Mittwochabend, Steinig, Frank Krieger, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, wir reden über Drohnen, haben wir jetzt also schon eine ganze Stunde gemacht, wir haben ein bisschen erklärt, wo die Dinge eigentlich herkommen, wir haben erklärt, was man damit machen kann, wer vor allen Dingen damit was machen. Also zum einen haben wir festgehalten, dass die Rechtsprechung oder die Gesetzeslage dafür noch überhaupt nicht ausreichend ist, wenn irgend so ein Ding unkontrolliert irgendwo vom Himmel fällt oder wo dagegen fliegt, was dann passiert, wer denn da irgendwie für den Schaden aufkommt.
Ja, also der, sagen wir mal, dieser ganze Raum der Verantwortlichkeit hängt halt sehr davon ab, wo diese Dinge eingesetzt werden. Also wenn wir jetzt mal annehmen, zum Beispiel wir fahren damit einfach durch die Gegend, es wird sehr einfach, also treffen wir auf einem Fußgänger oder auf ein anderes Auto, kann man sich das sehr einfach vorstellen. Kann man möglicherweise regeln wie ein Auto, aber wenn nehmen wir an, es handelt sich zum Beispiel um, wie gesagt, zum Beispiel diese Hüftgelenks-OP-Roboter, über die wir gerade gesprochen haben, ich hab gerade nochmal nachgeguckt, diese Firma hat einfach mal Insolvenz angemeldet. Die hatten halt irgendwie ein paar hundert Klagen am Hals in den USA. Und haben gesagt, können wir nichts machen, gehen wir mal insolvent. Und die Opfer standen dann im Wesentlichen nur mit so einer Minimalentschädigung aus irgendeinem Entschädigungsfond da. Und das ist natürlich kein befriedigender Zustand. Also die Verluste wurden halt vergesellschaftet in diesem Fall.
Womit wir bei dem Thema sind, was auch für den Chaos Computer Club und im Chaos Radio immer wieder auftaucht, nämlich die Freude an der technischen Entwicklung und an das Vortreiben der technischen Entwicklung und auf der anderen Seite natürlich auch irgendwie das Gefühl der Verantwortung, die man in dem Moment übernehmen muss, mal an technischen Geräten, welcher Art oder Art bastelt und diese weiter treibt.
Ja genau, also diese Verantwortung ist natürlich so ein Ding, was uns umtreibt. Also auf der einen Seite ist es natürlich so, dass man sagen kann, okay, sollten wir denn so eine Technologie anfassen, die momentan primär militärischen oder Überwachungsaspekte hat, auch wenn es halt einen Höllen Spaß macht, ist es dann richtig damit umzugehen, denen da den Stand des Wissens voranzutreiben oder sollte man eher sagen, wir lassen das lieber, wir fassen das nicht an, weil das ist eher böse. Also die Ansicht gibt es auch.
Sonst machen wir es noch besser und dann können die bösen Leute noch schlimmere Sachen damit machen.
Du bastelst ja, du bist ja richtig drin.
Wie siehst du das? Ich stehe auf dem Standpunkt, ich kann nur darüber reden, was ich verstehe und ich stehe auf dem Standpunkt, die Ideen, die guten Ideen, die kommen an vielen Orten gleichzeitig auf der Welt einfach, weil der Stand des Wissens da ist und weil sich eine Idee immer aus den Myriaden vorhergehender Ideen ergibt, fast schon zwangsläufig. Also deswegen bin ich auch so komplett gegen das Urheberrecht, weil letztlich ist das nicht meine Idee gewesen, die ich da hatte, sondern das ist die eine zusätzlich zu den 400 Trillionen Ideen, die von der ersten Gedankesleistung eines intelligenten Wesens bis heute nötig waren, über Feuerrad und die ganze Geschichte letztlich dazu zu führen, dass mir die Grundlage gegeben war, diese eine zusätzliche, fast schon zwangsläufige Idee oben drauf zu packen, aus der was angeblich scheinbar neu ist, völlig neu ist wurde, was ja gar nicht der Fall ist. Das heißt, diese Ideen entstehen sowieso. Machen wir uns nichts vor, es gibt bessere Drohnen als das, was wir heute bauen können. Wir haben die Möglichkeit, wir können die auch nicht wieder einfach wegmachen, wir können nur drüber reden, welche Verantwortung haben wir.
Man kann sie nicht mehr ignorieren.
Man kann sie nicht ignorieren. Sie werden irgendwann... Da oben, wenn ich nachts in den Himmel gucke, da fliegen sie ja zu Haufen, nennen sich Satelliten, ist im Prinzip genau das gleiche, gucken in meinen Garten. Tag wie Nacht, wenn die wollen.
Und die Dinge, womit wir diese Anfang der Sendung auch schonmal, was wir schonmal angeschnitten haben, es ist ja eben nicht nur jetzt ein von militärischen Organisationen oder militärischen Entwicklungen gebautes Ding, sondern du kannst für 700 Euro dir eine Drohne zusammen basteln und damit ist es ein ganz normaler Alltag.
Gut, dass man das jetzt kann, da muss man aufpassen, da sind wir jetzt nicht ganz unschuldig dran. Bis dato kosteten die halt so 10.000 bis 20.000 Euro. Und dann hab ich leichtfertigerweise vor zwei Jahren auf dem Chaos-Kongress mal behauptet, dass die sich für unter 1.000 Euro bauen lassen. Und dann gab es halt gleich zwei Teams, die das dann innerhalb eines Jahres, innerhalb eines halben Jahres auch realisiert hatten.
Daniel Düsentrieb, die sagen, die machen was.
Die sich da wirklich angestachelt fühlen. Ich glaube, Ingo und Holger haben vorher schon dran gebaut. Es passte aber, wie schon gesagt, die Ideen kommen an vielen Ecken gleichzeitig. Es passte wieder Arsch auf den Topf. Ein halbes Jahr später hatten wir die Dinge für unter 500 Euro am Start. Da sind sie nun und nun sind sie nicht gut genug.
Wenn ich mal den Advokat des Diabolos spielen darf, nur kurz vertrete ich meine Meinung, aber ich probiere es mal ein bisschen zu produzieren. Was man natürlich damit tut, ist ein Personalpool für die Leute schaffen, die halt militärische Drohnen bauen und die Sachen halt sehr viel billiger machen. Also man ist halt schon dabei, eine Industrie zu fördern, die im Wesentlichen gerade erstmal von militärischen und Überwachungssystemen lebt.
Das sieht die Firma Microdrone völlig anders.
Und man demokratisch... na wieso? Ich meine die Mikrokopter...
Ne die Mikrokopter, ja die Microdrone, das kommerzielle Unternehmen, die finden das total nicht gut. Also das habe ich da auch schon zu hören bekommen, wir würden hier Arbeitsplätze vernichten, wie es ist damals. Und dass das natürlich nicht so ist, haben die vielleicht mittlerweile auch verstanden. Ich hoffe das. Aber es ist jetzt schon nicht so... Also klar, was wir damit fördern, ist das Interesse an dieser Thematik. Und natürlich stimmt das. Das erweitert den Pool der Menschen, die sich damit beschäftigen. So, keine Frage. Das schafft aber auch eben einen bezahlbaren Preis, sodass eben nicht nur erlesene Kreise plötzlich imstande sind, sich da eine Flotte anzulegen, Ihre Nachbarn zu beobachten. Ja zum Beispiel, aber mindestens Greenpeace mal imstande ist, beim nächsten G8-Gipfel statt mit Schlauchbooten mit 400 Drohnen anzukommen. Und irgendeine wird es schon schaffen.
Also man kann das halt irgendwie eigentlich nicht schwarz-weiß betrachten, wie sie es jetzt schon. Also es ist halt wie immer bei Technologie-Entwicklung, man kann sich natürlich auf den Standpunkt stellen und sagen, okay, man fasst das Thema nicht an, weil man sich die Finger nicht schmutzig machen möchte.
Wenn du es nicht machst, macht es jemand anders.
Das ist so offensichtlich, dass man darüber eigentlich nicht diskutieren braucht. Für mich ist es halt wichtig, zu verstehen, was da passiert, welche Technologien an den Horizont des Machbaren kommen, wie billig die werden und wohin die Reise da geht. Deswegen finde ich, dass es unterstützen wird. Es gibt andere Leute, die sagen, wir sollten lieber die Finger davon lassen, wir sollten nicht noch fördern und featuren. Aber wie gesagt, das ist halt ein kontroverses Thema. Mich würde mal interessieren, wie die Hörer das sehen, ob ihnen diese Entwicklung Sorge macht, dass plötzlich lauter fliegende Kameras geben wird und jeder, die haben kann oder sich für rum so weit hinstellen können, dergleichen Dinge mehr.
Also Frage an euch, 03317097110, macht es euch sorgen, dass die technische Entwicklung soweit ist, dass die fliegende, unbebandte Überwachungskamera mittlerweile irgendwann auch vor eurem Fenster sein wird oder sagt ihr, es ist doch super, wenn die Technik sich weiter entwickelt. Das wäre schön, wenn ihr da euren Senf dazugeben möchtet, 0331 70 97 110. Die erste am Telefon ist Uli, die glaube ich uns noch ein bisschen aus diesem Versicherungsloch rausholen will.
Ja, hallo.
Ach du bist ein Ulrich, Uli.
Ja, genau.
Ich dachte, okay, tut mir leid.
Ja, was diesen Aspekt angeht, möchte ich eigentlich nur Folgendes dazu sagen. Die Problematik aus versicherungstechnischer Sicht liegt für meinen dafür weniger darin begründet, dass jetzt sich die Frage stellt, wer hat versagt oder wer hat einen Fehler respektive einer Unterlassung begangen. Sondern die Problematik liegt für mich eigentlich darin, dass diese Drohnen, die einen echten Schaden anrichten können, sprich militärische Drohnen oder Überwachungsdrohnen, von hohertlicher Seite betrieben werden. Und wenn du dir mal anschaust, wie die Haftung staatlicher Stellen, das hat jetzt gar nichts mit deutschen staatlichen Stellen zu tun, auf internationaler Ebene sieht das ähnlich aus, wie die aussieht im Vergleich zur Haftung von Privatpersonen, dann merkst du recht schnell, dass der Geschädigte dahingehend in den Arsch gekniffen ist.
Aber wenn wir jetzt mal nicht die militärischen nehmen, die waren ja, also wir reden ja schon von der privaten Nutzung.
Ja, bei der privaten Nutzung ist das relativ einfach. Hier haftet die Haftpflichtversicherung des Betreibers.
Bist du Versicherungsprofi eigentlich?
Ja, ich bin Versicherungsmakler.
Ah, okay, das ist klar.
Das ist relativ einfach. Wenn du da mit deiner Fernbedienung oder wie auch immer deine Drohne fliegen lässt und die rauscht beim Nachbarn ins Wohnzimmerfenster, ist das ein klassischer Fall erstmal für deine Privathaftpflicht. Und wenn du jetzt der Meinung bist, das ist halt deswegen passiert, weil die Software einen Bug hatte, dann hast du rein theoretisch die Möglichkeit über die sogenannte Durchgriffshaftung, die Produkthaftpflicht des Herstellers in Anspruch zu nehmen. Das Problem ist einfach, du müsstest halt die Beweisführung darlegen, dass das wirklich aufgrund dieses Software-Bugs passiert ist.
Und dann sind wir wieder beim Punkt, den wir in dieser Sendung ansprechen. Ich will wissen, wie so ein Ding funktioniert.
Genau, du willst wissen, wie so ein Ding funktioniert. Und wir sind außerdem bei dem großen Punkt, wo sitzt der Hersteller? Ist der Hersteller wirklich derjenige, welcher derhaftbar ist? Es könnte ja auch sein, dass das Ding irgendwo in Taiwan zusammengelötet worden ist und irgendein Importeur, der in den Niederlanden sitzt, hat es importiert. Hat ja seinen Namen als Label draufgebabt. Das gilt als sogenannter Quasi-Importeur. Da will ich jetzt gar nicht ins Detail gehen. Das wird einmal zu kompliziert.
Das Problem eskizziert sich jetzt schon mal ganz grob. Also das hätten wir geklärt mit der Versicherung.
Das ist absolut kein Thema. Das war ja schon vor Drohnen der Fall, als man irgendwelche Flugmodelle fliegen liest. Also da ist an sich die Problematik nicht zu sehen. Was die Frage angeht, wegen der technischen Entwicklung. Also die Technik wird sich weiter entwickeln, ob uns das jetzt gefällt oder nicht. Und wir leben ja nun mal nicht irgendwie auf dem Planet oder auf der Insel der Glücksseligen. Das heißt, wenn das bei uns passiert, dann passiert das halt außerhalb unserer Landesgrenzen. Maßgeblich ist für meinen Geschmack eigentlich eher die Frage, was machen wir mit dieser Technologie? Missbrauchen wir sie für irgendwelche Schweinereien? Oder nutzen wir sie für sinnvolle Zwecke? Und was die Überwachungsproblematik angeht, also wer dich überwachen will, der konnte es auch in der Vergangenheit tun. Da musst du wahrscheinlich einen weitaus höheren Personalaufwand betreiben. Das haben uns ja die Herrschaften vom MFS über Jahrzehnte deutlich demonstriert, was da alles möglich ist. Und da sind wir wieder bei einem Punkt, wofür setzt sich die Technologie ein? Wofür die damals vielleicht 50 IEMs gebraucht haben? Das könntest du heute mit moderner Kommunikations-Elektronik mit einer Person bewirkt bleiben. Aber deswegen die Weiterentwicklung der Technologie zu verdammen, das hier dich definitiv für den falschen Weg.
Guter Ansatz, danke dir.
Bitte, danke schön. Schönen Abend noch.
Wir haben noch einen Anrufer und zwar Hannes, der kommt mit einer ganz spannenden Frage um die Ecke. Hallo Hannes. Hallo, wie alt bist du nun weg? Also noch nicht so im Hyper-Programmierer und Nerd-Alter.
Es fängt gerade an. Ich bin bei den Programmiersprachen schon mal reingeschnuppert. Ich bin tatsächlich auch so ein bisschen im Modellbau interessiert und so und mich beschäftigt ist jetzt schon länger die Frage auch, was man machen kann bei solchen Drohnen, um die quasi, also wenn diese Geschichte, wenn jetzt so ein Ding über dir schwebt, was machst du dann so? Und du kannst natürlich schön winken und so, aber mir ist irgendwie eingefallen, also einmal so Störsender, aber wenn die jetzt autonom fliegen, dann bringen ja Störsender so richtig auch nichts mehr. Also ja, keine Ahnung, ihr habt ganz am Anfang der Sendung, deswegen rufe ich auch an, mal kurz angesprochen, dass ihr da mal zu kommen wollt und da dachte ich, ich stoße jetzt einfach mal an.
Also die Frage, was kann man denn tun? Also da hängen natürlich wieder viel von den technischen Details ab, also eine gute Möglichkeit, die man nur gegen Drohnen verwenden sollte, aber sicherlich keinesfalls gegen Mimantel-Luftfahrzeuge ist, die Kamera im Laser zu blenden. Da reicht einfach auch ein dickerer Laserpointer, so einer von den grünen irgendwie 10mW-Dingern, die irgendwie machen doch irgendwie schon einen hinreichenden starken Lichtpunkt, wie gesagt, auf gar keinen Fall gegen Mimantel-Luftfahrzeuge machen, das hochgradig strafbereingegangenen Luftverkehr entwirkt und mehreren Jahren Knast geahndet zurecht.
Wie so was passiert dann?
Du kannst halt den Piloten blenden. Und wie gesagt, solche Hemmungen muss man halt gegen Drohnen nicht haben.
Aber wenn da kein Pilot drin sitzt, wie soll ich denn? Da kann ich auch keinen blenden.
Dann ist die Kamera.
Die geht dann nicht mehr.
Die geht dann halt nicht mehr.
Die hat dann überall schwarze, hektische Flecken.
Genau, oder hellgrüne oder was auch immer. Das ist ein sehr effektiver Weg, der auch, denke ich mal, nicht illegal ist. Nee, würde mir jetzt gar nicht irgendwie so illegal sein sollte. Wenn man sich dann halt natürlich noch ein bisschen weiter beschäftigt, kann man natürlich seine eigene Drohne starten und damit die andere Drohne abdrängen oder zum Absturz bringen. Das ist sicherlich auch eine Methode, die man sicherlich nicht über bewohnten Gebieten machen sollte.
Ja, vielleicht sollten wir zur nächsten Motodrohne dann einen Dogfight machen oder so irgendwas, wie man mal... Also das Problem wird real. Ich hatte das auf dem Kongress auch schon gesagt. Ich sehe von meinem geistigen Auge irgendwie drei Bohlen-Drohnen gegen 20 Paparazzi-Drohnen. Also das wird kommen, die Bohlen-Villa wird dann ständig von irgendwelchen Dingen umschwirrt, die dann halt immer mal wieder landen, sich automatisch aufladen, wieder losfliegen. Auch eine mögliche Challenge, wie lande ich dann automatisch auf einer Ladestation? Und ständig ist so ein Ding in der Luft und guckt, ob Paparazzi-Journalie-Drohnen da am Start sind.
Sind solche Dinge eigentlich, wir haben jetzt viel über öffentliche Einsätze gesprochen, also Polizei, Feuerwehr, Tralala, ist sowas auch schon irgendwie im journalistischen Bereich irgendwie aufgetaucht, dass jetzt genau das Beispiel Paparazzi irgendwelche Luxus-Villen von oben abfilmen mit so einem Ding?
Also ich hab's noch, mir ist noch nicht aufgefallen, aber es kann nicht mehr lange dauern. Also es wird sicherlich nicht mehr lange dauern.
Die fliegen doch schon mit Helikoptern rum, also warum dann nicht auch mit sowas?
Genau, also es kann sich nur noch um Monate handeln, denk ich mal so.
Ich glaub die effizienteste Methode, um sich momentan eine Micro-Drone zu holen, ist der stärkere Sender. Die sind nämlich in keiner Weise irgendwie geschützt, das ist ein ganz normales Fernsteuersystem, handelsüblich. Ich brauch einfach nur einen dickeren Endstufentransistor in meine Fernbedienung eingebaut und dann ist sie meiner.
Achso, weil du dann die Kontrolle überlegst?
Ja klar, der stärkste Träger gewinnt.
Und wenn sie niedrig fliegt, reicht das für eine Wasserpistole?
Ja genau, das wollte ich wissen. Wie autonom sind denn die Geschichten schon? Die haben schon immer noch so ein...
Also im Moment wird der GPS primär dazu verwendet, den stabil in der Luft zu halten?
Also könnte man quasi auch, wenn man jetzt nicht irgendwie die passende Fernsteuerung parat hat, so ein Störsender ist ja schnell gebaut.
Ja, wenn der Störsender greift, bleibt das Ding auf der Stelle stehen, bis der Akku alle ist und landet dann, wo er ist. Das ist so das Protokoll bei der Micro-Drone im Augenblick. Also die fallen nicht einfach runter? Die fallen nicht einfach runter. Das ist ein Luftnagel, der hat GPS. Wenn da irgendwas nicht stimmt, gibt es zwei Modi, die kann man einstellen. Der eine ist, bleib da, wo du bist, guck, ob du es wiederkriegst. Wenn nicht, lande. Und die andere Variante ist, fliegt genau die Strecke zurück, die du gekommen bist. Das ist dann schon sehr schwierig. Aber den stärkeren Sender zu haben, dann ist sie meine.
Also eine andere illegale Methode wäre halt, einen GPS-Jammer zu bauen. Das heißt, es ist ein Störsender, der das GPS-Signal stört. Das ist aber in Deutschland illegal. Man kann die zwar im Internet kaufen, aber wie gesagt, die Verwendung ist seit der Einführung der Autobahn-Maut illegal. Da darf man also das Navigationssignal von GPS nicht stören. Das würde aber auch dazu führen, dass im Zweifel die Drohne irgendwie entweder nicht mehr stabil fliegt oder abhaut.
Und gibt es da schon irgendwelche Verschlüsselungstechniken? Oder ist das, also ich kann mir das gar nicht vorstellen.
Bei dem Mikrodrohnen nicht, nein.
Nee, aber es wird halt nicht mehr lange dauern, also bei den meteorischen Drohnen sind die Steuerprotokolle alle verschlüsselt und gehärtet.
Gut Hannes, wir hoffen, wir haben jetzt deinen kleinen Rucksack gepackt, sollst du dir morgen eine Drohne über den Weg fliegen, dass du genau weißt, was du da tust. Erst Wink und dann Wasserzister.
Genau, also ansonsten kann man natürlich auch noch irgendwie, keine Ahnung, so was wie Tonmummel mit der Zwille oder so was ausprobieren.
Ja, da muss man aber schon gut mit der Zwille.
Das ist mir ein paar Spaßfüllen. Patrick ist am Telefon, danke dir Hannes.
Ich hab eine Idee, wie man das machen kann. Und zwar gibt es da, wenn ihr bei Google eingibt, Thumbmobile Zapper, gibt es einen Heiseartikel, wie man aus einer Mikrowelle das mal mit einem Neutron nimmt und mit einer Satellitenschüssel gegen den gewünschten Gegenstand richtet und das Ding einfach mal kaputt macht.
Das ist auch nicht so gänzlich legal.
Nee, nicht so richtig.
Wieso, wenn die von meinem Haus fliegt, die Drohne? Auf meinem Grundstück.
Also das Problem ist halt eher, dass du eine Mikrowelle umzubauen, also da sozusagen, das ist halt, nun sagen wir, ich würde das nicht empfehlen für den Hausgebrauch.
Nee, das würde ich auch nicht empfehlen.
Also so ein Mangetron kann halt relativ schnell zur Erhitzung von wasserhaltigen Körperteilen auf relativ hohe Temperaturen führen.
Das ist so, ich mein, man kann auch Sprengstoff selber bauen und diverse, man kann auch versuchen, mit einer Kartoffelkanone nach der Drohne zu schießen.
Ja, man kann auch versuchen, sich Knopper in die Backe zu nähen und Klavier dran zu hängen. Genau.
Oder so lange dran drehen, bis Radio Luxemburg kommt.
Das wollen wir. Das Ding ist aber auf jeden Fall kaputt. Die Kippen sind da drin gebraten.
Nee, du kannst, also mal so eine Drohne gegen 2, 4 GHz Abtischung ist relativ trivial. Du brauchst eigentlich dazu nur im Wesentlichen das Gehäuse von Metalllack sprühen und an die größte Metallstelle an dem Gehäuse füllen. Genau, das ist halt relativ trivial zu machen. Gerade bei meteorischen Drohnen ist das auch total üblich. Die werden halt gegen EMP gehärtet. Also da gewinnt man nicht so viel, außer Ärger mit den Nachbarn.
Siehst du, Patrick, also auch du mit einer Wasserpistole einfach.
Wasserpistole und Laser, ja.
Genau, also Laser gegen die Kamera blenden, das ist im Zweifel das Einfassende.
Am Telefon ist Christian. Hallo Christian, grüß dich.
Ja, hallo.
Der erste heute Abend, der nicht hurra schreit, wenn wir über Drohnen reden.
Ja, genau. Wie gesagt, also ich verfolge die Sendung durch Zufall, weil ich hier oben in dem Raum am Arbeiten bin bei euch, komme eigentlich aus der Koblenzerkante unten. Und wie gesagt, bin total schockiert, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, über das Thema, wo ihr da sprecht, dass das überhaupt schon so akut ist, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, bin ich total baff. Also ich wusste zwar, dass es so welche gibt und dass so etwas auch verwendet wird, vielleicht im militärischen Bereich, aber dass da im privaten Bereich schon im Prinzip spioniert wird mit den Dingern und so weiter, also ist für mich absolut neu, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Du musst mal gucken im Internet, Mikrokopter, also Mikro mit K und Kopter auch mit k.com oder.de. Da gibt es sogar ein Video, wie die so ein Ding starten. Also so ein kleines Modellflugzeug, starten die aus der Hand und dann kannst du mit der Kamera sehen, was die Drohne alles sieht. Du hast echt das Gefühl, du sitzt im Fernsehen.
Also wie gesagt, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, ich hab von dem ganzen technischen Kram da mit der Drohne keine Ahnung, muss ich ganz ehrlich dazu sagen. Ich bin so ein Computerfreak nicht, muss ich sagen, aber ich bin total schockiert. Dass die im Prinzip so verwendet werden, sind den ganzen Kram schon im privaten Bereich.
Jetzt noch mal die Frage an die Experten, um den Einwand von Christian aufzugreifen. Wir haben jetzt eineinhalb Stunden schon über Drohnen geredet. Wie dramatisch oder akut ist diese Thematik jetzt wirklich im normalen privaten Leben?
Momentan haben wir keine Ahnung, wie viele Leute werden es vielleicht in Deutschland gebaut haben? 150 oder was?
Ja, insgesamt, aber geh mal davon aus, dass zwei Drittel das entweder nicht fertig gekriegt haben oder nicht mehr interessiert.
Oder es irgendwie gegen den nächsten Baum geflogen haben. Die Fakt ist, es geht. Also es geht. Deswegen, wir reden ja immer gerne relativ früh über Technik, wenn sie halt absehbar wird, dass es kommt, dann kann man rechtzeitig drüber nachdenken. Es ist jetzt noch nicht so, dass du jetzt damit rechnen musst, dass der Nachbar schon so ein Ding über deinen Pool fliegt. Das wäre sehr unwahrscheinlich. Aber es abzusehen, dass es nicht mehr lange dauern kann, bis es bei Chibo eine China-Drohne für 200 Euro gibt, die genau diese totet. Es kann sich maximal nach zwei Jahren handeln bis die Technologie soweit ist. Deswegen reden wir darüber, um darauf aufmerksam zu machen, was schon heute geht und in naher Zukunft passieren wird.
Und wo die unterschiedlichen Problematiken sind. Und wenn du anrufst Christian und sagst, ich wusste nicht, dass es soweit ist, ist vielleicht damit schon eins der Ziele dieser Sendung erreicht, nämlich überhaupt mal darüber zu reden, dass es Dinge auf dieser Welt gibt.
Absolut richtig. Ich bin total begeistert von der Sendung. Kann man nicht anders sagen.
Allerdings.
Danke dir für deinen Anruf, Christian. Und falls ihr gerade reingeschaltet habt und die gesamte Sendung nochmal hören wollt, überhaupt kein Problem. Es gibt davon ein Podcast, einfach chaosradio.ccc.de. Wir machen jetzt die Nachrichten und danach reden wir weiter über Drohnen.
Lauschen wir nun einer Kurzbotschaft der Beatstakes. Sensation! Grande Finale! Fritz präsentiert das Berlin-Konzert der Beatstakes live im Radio. Das ausverkaufte Tour-Finale der Beatstakes live im Fritz-Radio-Konzert. Freitag, 29.
fritz.de Und?
Die allerletzten Tickets zum Live-Dabei sein haben wir auch noch. Einfach gut fritz hören. Das ausverkaufte Berlin-Konzert der Beatstakes live im Radio. Freitag, 29.
Nach dem Absturz einer Passagiermaschine auf dem Flughafen von Madrid wird die Zahl der Toten immer weiter nach oben korrigiert. Wie die Regionalregierung in Madrid mitteilte, kamen 153 Menschen ums Leben. 19 seien schwer verletzt worden. Ein Sprecher sagte, an Bord der Unglücksmaschine seien 172 Personen gewesen. Rangaben der Fluggesellschaft Lufthansa könnten auch Deutsche unter den Opfern sein. Für den Flug der Spanischen Gesellschaft Spanair hätten auch vier Deutsche eingecheckt. Die Maschine war unmittelbar nach dem Start in Richtung Gran Canaria zerschellt. Im Georgien-Konflikt verschärft sich der Ton zwischen der Europäischen Union und Russland. Der französische Außenminister und EU-Ratsvorsitzende Kuschner warf Präsident Medvedev Wortbruch vor. Ein größerer Abzug russischer Truppen aus Georgien sei nach wie vor nicht erkennbar. Das sei eine Missachtung internationaler Vereinbarungen, die so nicht hingenommen werden könne, so Kuschner. Medvedev hatte sich vertraglich zum Rückzug der Truppen verpflichtet. Er soll bis Freitagnacht abgeschlossen sein. Bis dahin will die NATO ihre militärische Zusammenarbeit mit Russland ruhen lassen. Die Bundesregierung will die Bürger besser vor Handy-Strahlung schützen. Umweltminister Gabriel kündigte dazu einen Gesetzentwurf an. Die Mobilfunkstrahlung nehme zu. Darauf müsse die Politik reagieren, sagten Gabriel und der Präsident des Bundesamts für Strahlenschutz König bei der Vorstellung des Strahlenschutzjahresberichts. Zur Abwehr von Hautkrebs durch künstliche UV-Strahlen bekräftigte Gabriel die Absicht, Minderjährigen und Jugendlichen den Besuch von Sonnenstudios zu verbieten. Beide Vorhaben sollen in das neue Umweltgesetzbuch aufgenommen werden. Start! Die deutsche Fußball-Nationalmannschaft hatte Nürnberg ihr erstes Testspiel nach der Europameisterschaft 2 zu 0 gegen Belgien gewonnen. Bastian Schweinsteiger verwandelte in der 59. Minute einen faul 11 Meter und in der 77. Minute traf Marco Marin für Deutschland. Heute Nacht ist es meist trocken bei Tiefstwerten bis 12 Grad. Am Tag dann ein Wechsel aus Sonne und Wolken, dabei nur selten kurzer Schauer. Die Höchstwerte liegen bei 25 Grad. A2 Berlin Richtung Magdeburg. Zwischen Brandenburg an der Havel und Voliden gibt es Gefahr durch einen defekten LKW, da ist die rechte Spur und die Anstoßstelle Voliden blockiert. Stadtverkehr Berlin A100 der Stadtring Richtung Wedding am Tempelhofer Damm ist die Ausfahrt gesperrt und wird gebaut. Es ist aber eine Umleitung eingerichtet. Sonst überall gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 101, 5? Dann Fritz in Eisenhüttenstadt.
Blum, die zwei Sprechstunden. Chaosradio, wir reden über Drohnen, kurze Gorillas und dann gehts weiter. In Chaos Radio auf Fritz, Nummer 138. Frank-Ri-Gon Steini sind hier, wir reden über Drohnen und wir hatten gerade eine lange ausführliche Diskussion darüber, ob man sich da jetzt Sorgen machen muss oder auch nicht. Mit der Frage, ich wusste gar nicht, dass die Entwicklung bei Drohnen schon so weit ist. Wir hatten ja auch erwähnt, dass Drohnen mittlerweile für relativ schmalen Trailer als Bausatz auch zu kriegen sind. Wie ist denn da ansonsten in der Welt der Roboter der Stand der technischen Entwicklung? Was kommt da noch? Was dazu, Frank?
Was momentan läuft, ist primär das, was man vielleicht als Telepräsenz bezeichnen könnte. Das heißt also, die Autonomie dieser Systeme beschränkt sich im Wesentlichen darauf, dass sie eben erstmal von selber irgendwo gegenfliegen oder zumindest irgendwie einen Punkt erreichen von selbst, aber doch immer noch ein Operator mit dabei ist. Also dass die Dinger selbstständig komplette Missionen fliegen, ist noch nicht der Fall. Genauso ist es auch bei den Bodenbewegten Systemen wie zum Beispiel diesen Wachroboter nicht der Fall. Die sind halt erstmal Verlängerungen der Sinne des Menschen. Also sie können halt deine Sinne irgendwo hin transportieren, wo du gerade nicht sein kannst oder willst. Das hat auch schon eine sehr lange Tradition, also Bombenentschaffungsroboter, die Dinger, die sie in Kernkraftwerken einsetzen, wenn sie da den Scheiß aufräumen müssen, nach Tscharnobyl zum Beispiel oder bei Chemieunfällen und so. Solche Sachen gibt es ja schon sehr lange und die werden aber gewinnen immer mehr an Autonomität. Das heißt, die können immer mehr Dinge selber tun, um die du dich dann nicht drum kümmern musst. Dann einfach sagen kannst, fahr mal den Flur runter und dann fährt der Ding den Flur runter und fährt von selber um und fährt Schutthaufen drum rum. Das sind halt so die, also da wird halt sehr viel Energie reingesteckt, weil dafür sehr viele praktische Anwendungsfälle gibt. Und was ich schon erwarte ist, dass sowas zum Beispiel verwendet werden kann, dass du körperlich irgendwo anwesend sein kannst, wo du gerade nicht hinfliegen willst. Also dass es zum Beispiel einen Roboter gibt, der dich auf einer Konferenz vertritt. Der kann erstmal im Rollstuhl sitzen, weil dafür ist die Welt mittlerweile auch eingerichtet, zumindest im Westen. Oder vielleicht später kann er auf zwei Beinen laufen und hat halt irgendwie eine Projektion von dem Gesicht reingeklebt und kann für dich halt Hände schütteln auf einer Konferenz, wo du gerade nicht anwesend sein kannst. So eine Anwendung wird es relativ viele, denke ich mal auch relativ bald geben. Dann ist sicherlich dieser ganze Bereich mehr so Haushaltshilfen, Krankentransport, Exoskelette, das ist auch so ein Ding, ist ja de facto so ein Roboter, denke da wird sehr viel passieren. Also weil so ein Exoskelett ist eine Sache, die wollen wir eigentlich alle haben. Wenn wir irgendwie 70 und klapprig sind, dann wollen wir trotzdem noch irgendwie selber die Treppen hoch gehen können. Das heißt, wir wollen halt einen Iron Man Style.
Du ziehst ja quasi so einen Anzug an, der für dich, die dich bei den Bewegungen unterstützt.
Genau, ich setze mich in einen Roboter, der im Prinzip meine Außenhülle stabilisiert und mit Kraft versieht.
Also in dem Bereich gibt es ja speziell in Japan schon eine Menge Entwicklungen, wo es um Reha-Technik und Reha-Roboter geht. Da sind die ja sehr fit.
Genau, da machen die eine ganze Menge, einfach bedingt durch die bealtrohende Gesellschaft und ihren Hightech-Filmen, denen sie ohnehin haben, sodass die Einsatzschwelle relativ gering. Dann ist eine ganze Menge passiert im Bereich Spezialanwendung, Fensterputzroboter auf großen Glasflächen, Staubsauger-Roboter.
Da fährt doch einer am Hauptbahnhof über die Glasflächen.
Genau, da fährt so ein Ding vielleicht darüber.
Wer ist jetzt verantwortlich, wenn der Runde fällt?
Ja, interessante Frage. Ich glaube, er ist festgeputt. Na gut, da fällt noch ein anderer Stahlträger.
Kann man da mit einer Drohne hinfahren und den einfach einsacken? Achso, dann brauchst du eine Schraubdohne.
Da muss ich überhaupt kurz mal Fensterputzroboter, da muss ich eine Story loswerden. Da war ich so platt, da war irgendwo so ein unbedeutender und so ein kleines Artikel über den Entwicklung, dass sie elektrostatische Adhessionen jetzt irgendwie mal in richtig gemacht haben. Das ist jetzt kurz ein bisschen technisch. Die haben im Prinzip eine Folie genommen, legen da massiv Spannung an und jeder kennt das, wenn man so einen Luftballon am Pulli reibt, dann klebt der an der Decke. Was ich nicht wusste, was wir dann aber mal nachrecherchiert haben, man kann tatsächlich mit der Energie aus einer AA, einer Mignon-Zelle, kann man genug Elektroadhession erzeugen um 100 Kilo an die Decke zu hängen. Da war ich richtig platt.
Also die haben jetzt Roboter gebaut, die können Wände hochgehen.
Und zwar ganz gleich, was das für ein Material ist. Aufgrund dieser Elektroadhession, genau. Auf dieser elektrostatischen Adhession. Da war ich richtig platt.
Wenn du sagst, die bauen sowas, wer ist und wer baut sowas?
Das sind meistens jetzt irgendwelche universitären Entwicklungen. Ich bin unsicher, es kam irgendwie aus den USA. Ich hab's jetzt nicht mehr, es ist schon ein bisschen her.
Was man jetzt schon kaufen kann im privaten Bereich, sind diese Staubsaugerroboter.
Die durch deine Wohnung fahren und dann vor dem Aquarium umdrehen und wieder zurückfahren.
Genau, die sind halt noch ein bisschen laut, aber ansonsten funktionieren die eigentlich ganz gut. Der Staubbeutel ist ein bisschen kleiner.
Aber, und das war der echte Durchbruch letztlich, die finden jetzt ihre Basisstation wieder und können sich selber wieder aufladen.
Genau, also du musst die nicht mehr irgendwie...
Das ist das, was du vorhin sagtest, nimm eine Drohne und sag ihr bitte, du fährst zur Aufladestation und fliegst wieder über Bodentau.
Das ist der nächste Schritt, weil momentan haben wir 15 Minuten mit so einer Drohne, das reicht für nichts. Außer mal eben schnell kurz gucken. Was man will ist, die haben eine Stunde Ladezeit, 20 Minuten Flugzeit, ich hab drei Stück, es ist immer einer in der Luft, und zwar ohne, dass ich mich kümmere. Dazu reicht es ja, dass sie immer über meinem Haus schwebt und sich langsam im Kreis dreht und ein Überwachungsturm spielt, sagen wir mal, und dann wieder landet und dann kommt die, also auch keine komplexe Bewegung, aber das wird in aller nächster Zukunft kommen, das haben wir noch nächstes Jahr.
Eine Idee, was man noch machen kann, hat Jorg zum Beispiel angerufen, 0331 77 97 110, hallo Jorg.
Ja, ich hab letztes Jahr bei eurer Blumen-Sendung zu Drohnen mich schon mal ein bisschen beteiligt. Ganz witzig, eigentlich komme ich selten dazu, Blumen zu hören, aber wenn ihr euch über Drohnen unterhaltet, läuft es mir immer über den Weg. Ja, also ich wollte mal dazu sagen, ihr habt ja jetzt viel darüber geredet, was Drohnen so für Gefahren bedeuten könnten in Zukunft oder was ist für den einzelnen für Einschränkungen dadurch.
Na, wir haben nur versucht, diese allgemeine Hurra-Thematik ein bisschen zu korrigieren.
Ja, aber das Problem, was ich dabei sehe, oder beziehungsweise den Punkt, den ich dabei sehe, ist, dass man heutzutage eigentlich durch Handys, durch Internet etc. PP, also dadurch, dass heutzutage eigentlich alles digitalisiert abläuft, was man früher halt per Hand gemacht hat, man ja schon viel überwachter ist, als es so eine Drohne heutzutage, also zumindest im zivilen Bereich, jetzt für den Bürger leisten könnte.
Aber das ist halt ein Baustein mehr, ne? Der Punkt ist halt, man kann es halt nicht gegeneinander abwägen. Es ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt dadurch, dass es Drohnen gibt, ist die Internetüberwachung weg. Sondern es ist halt so, dass der Baustein dazukommt, dass auf der Basis der Position, die zum Beispiel aus dem Mobiltelefon zu erzählen ist, dass es sehr einfach ist, eine Drohne zu schicken, die dich dann auch noch föhnt.
Genau, aber dazu muss man ja im Prinzip schon im Visier sein. Also was schon eine Drohne im Prinzip macht, ist, wenn irgendwo ein Verdacht ist, wenn die Einsatzkräfte oder wer auch immer das Ding jetzt verwendet, jetzt in irgendeiner Form noch ein weiteres Werkzeug braucht, um jetzt sagen wir mal ihre Arbeit zu tun, oder was auch immer sie da tun. Also wir leben ja zum Glück nicht in einem Überwachungsstaat, wie zu DDR-Zeiten. Sodass man eigentlich schon davon ausgehen kann, dass damit verantwortungsvoll umgegangen wird.
Was veranlasst dich dazu? Also wo kommt diese Theorie her, dass damit verantwortungsvoll umgegangen wird?
Das ist jetzt keine Theorie, sondern das ist einfach meine Beobachtung unserer heutigen Gesellschaft, dass einfach in der Bundesrepublik, also ich muss dazu sagen, ich bin aus dem Osten, mit Daten, solange sie zumindest öffentlich gehandhabt werden, oder auch eben mit solchen Mitteln wie Drohnen, oder was die Polizei oder sonst die Einsatzkräfte eben sonst an Möglichkeiten haben, um jetzt dem Bürger in irgendeiner Form zu schaden, dass das schon verantwortungsvoll eingesetzt wird.
Du hast den aktuellen Skandal komplett nicht mitgekriegt.
Der aktuelle Skandal handelt erst mal kommerzielle Sachen.
Ja und was glaubst du, wo die Informationen alle herkommen?
Die kommen von Callcentern, das hat ja jetzt zum Beispiel mit Polizei oder Feuerwehr etc.
Nein, natürlich und es gab auch noch nie den Fall, dass der Konsul des Schwagers, der bei der Polizei ist, dann mal eben schnell rausgefunden hat, für wen diese Autonummer da ist. Also ein ganz heikles Thema.
Ich möchte mich jetzt ehrlich gar nicht so in diese Richtung mit der Diskussion bewegen, weil wir immer schon mal kurz dabei sind, dass ich kenne auch Polizisten und die sagen, wenn sie ein Autokennzeichen ermitteln wollen, dann brauchen die einen Fall dazu. Das kann man nicht einfach so machen. Wir sind ein sehr bürokratischer Staat, da wird immer überall versucht, entsprechende Netze einzuziehen, dass eben so ein Klügel nicht entstehen kann. Vorgebeugt wird, natürlich kann man es nicht immer verhindern, aber es wird nicht flächendechend gemacht. Wir befinden uns nicht in einem Staat.
Die Frage ist folgende. Warum dann weigern sich die Innenminister standhaft, polizeiliche Maßnahmen, die genehmigt werden, entweder zeitlich zu begrenzen oder wissenschaftlich zu evaluieren?
Ein Innenminister ist ein Politiker, den würde ich da jetzt nicht...
Nein, nein, nein, das sind auch so Leute wie z.B. der BKA-Präsident, der weigert sich und sagt, wir gewollen keine wissenschaftliche Evaluation, weil wir sonst möglicherweise die politische Rückendeckung verlieren. Weil bei dieser Evaluation z.B. rauskommt, dass die Polizei ihren Benachrichtigungspflichten bei Bewachungsmaßnahmen nicht mal einem Drittel der Fälle nachkommt. Weil z.B. dabei rauskommt, dass bei Telefonüberwachung, im Gegensatz zu vielen anderen Ländern, keine Ermittlungen stattfindet, wie erfolgreich das eigentlich ist. Also in wie viel Prozent der Fälle tatsächlich z.B. eine Verurteilung kommt. Ja, es gibt es nicht, weil es wird politisch verweigert. Und aus diesem Grund bin ich enorm skeptisch, dass damit verantwortlich umgegangen wird.
Ich habe kein Problem damit, dass man skeptisch ist. Das ist auch immer gut, man muss die Sachen natürlich hinterfragen. Aber auf der anderen Seite muss man natürlich auch sehen, welche Möglichkeiten, und auch im positiven Sinne, betrachtet jetzt Drohnen eben nicht nur für die Polizei, sondern eben auch für kommerziellen Einsatz. Also wenn es um, keine Ahnung, Hochspannungsleitungen überwacht. Oder Waldbrände früher entdecken, alles solche Sachen. Also man kann mit Drohnen unheimlich viel anfangen, was man heutzutage natürlich, wenn man es denn machen will, sehr teuer mit bemanter Luftfahrt machen muss.
Na ja, oder mit allen anderen Sachen. Das haben wir auch gerade angeschnitten, dass die Drohne einfach im Zweifelsfall, oder das unbemannte Objekt, welches auch immer, einfach dahin gehen kann, wo Menschenleben in Gefahr sind. Also was weiß ich, irgendwelche Katastrophenherde oder Unfallgeschichten.
Obwohl es nur der seltenste Fall ist, aber oft hat man halt eben, dass man Sachen, wo man wirklich jetzt Sachen, die jetzt keinen persönlichen Schaden, wie zum Beispiel Weitbrennen oder sonst was macht.
Jaja, so hatten wir alles, haben wir aber eingangs ja auch diskutiert. Der Architekt, der eben seine Baustelle auch mal anguckt.
Ich habe jetzt eure Sendung nicht von anderen verfolgt.
Da fehlt dir jetzt genau dieser Teil.
Ist klar, ist überhaupt auch nicht schlimm. Wir wollten ja auch hier nicht sagen, dass Drohnen böse böse böse sind, sondern einfach nur darauf hinweisen, wie weit die technische Entwicklung schon ist, dass du so ein Ding für unter 1000 Euro bauen kannst und los schicken kannst und wohin die technische Entwicklung dann noch geht und welche Pros und Contras da links und rechts vom Wege liegen, das können wir hier in der 2-Stunden-Sendung natürlich gar nicht anreißen.
Die Pros gerade jetzt von der Tatsache, dass die Drohne jetzt auch beim Mikrokopter und so weiter und so fort immer günstiger und einfacher wird, sehe ich einfach, dass sie nicht mehr ausschließlich militärisch genutzt wird. Weil militärische Nutzung ist immer dann, wenn das Militär quasi für viele Millionen, die können ja mit einem Heidengeld darin versenken, quasi eine Technologie für sich allein nutzen kann.
Jetzt kommt gleich wahrscheinlich die Theorie mit der Teflon-Fanne und der Raumfahrt.
Also für uns ist halt das Problem, dass wenn so neue Technologie anfängt, in Benutzung zu kommen, dann muss man sich halt darüber Gedanken machen, benötigt das eine Regulierung? Wenn ja, wie soll die aussehen? Natürlich, klar. Also ist es z.B. notwendig, bei den Modellflugzeugen oder besseren Modellflugzeugen mit GPS und einer Kamera unten dran, sind wir vermutlich noch nicht in dem Bereich, wo man sagt, ok, da braucht man eine Regulierung, wenn die Dinge aber plötzlich wirklich in großen Massen eingesetzt werden können, weil sie enorm billig geworden sind. Und wenn du einfach mal, als nur Spaß halber annimmst, du könntest einfach 1000 von den Dingern permanent über Berlin in der Luft haben.
Das geht ja nun gerade bei den Mikrokoptern um, die sicher sagen, wenn wir diese Theorie über Berlin haben, dann sagen wir, wir bewegen uns im elektrischen Bereich unter 5 Kilo, das sind dann diese Mikrodrohnen, die können ja nun nicht länger als 20 Minuten in der Luft bleiben.
Das ist vollkommen in Ordnung, wenn du 5000 Stück hast, dann hast du 2500 auf der Leiterstadt und 2500 an der Luft. Also wir müssen einfach darüber nachdenken, wie sehen so eine Szenarien aus?
Das wäre im Prinzip genau das Gleiche, wenn es schon heute darum geht, wer da seine Filiale auf der Straße, Bankfiliale oder was auch immer, mit einer Kamera wie weit überwachen, ohne dass er Persönlichkeitsrechte verlässt.
Genau, da gibt es eben diese Thematik.
Im Prinzip ist das ja schon abgedeckt, wenn man so will. Weil dazu gibt es Rechtsprechung, damit wurde sich befasst. Und eine Drohne ist ja nichts weiter als eine sich bewegende Kamera. Deshalb muss man es letztendlich nur auf die Drohne übertragen.
Genau, nur montan passiert das halt noch nicht. Das sind halt so die Dinge, die uns da bewegen. Und pauschal zu sagen, ich vertraue unseren Ermittlungsbehörden, weil bisher haben sie keinen Scheiß gebaut. Ne, so blöd bin ich nicht.
Nein, so wollte ich das auch nicht verstanden wissen. Ich wollte nur sagen, dass man eben auch sehen muss, dass diese Drohne eben auch sehr nützlich ist. Auch in der Hand der Polizei, selbst wenn wir nicht immer der Polizei vertrauen wollen.
Unbestritten, ja.
Ja, das war im Prinzip mein Beitrag dazu.
Alles klar, danke dir viermals.
Danke auch, tschüss.
Wir haben auch eine Mail bekommen, die wollen wir nicht vorenhalten. Und zwar von Lars. Der hat geschrieben, er kann sich ganz gut vorstellen, dass es bald selbstverständlich ist, mit Drohnen zu leben. Wenn die Technik erstmal so klein ist durch die Nanotechnologie, werden die auch nur noch verschwindend klein sein. Er findet das Thema sehr spannend, schön. Gruß Lars. Also, eine Menge passiert. Auf jeden Fall konnten wir wahrscheinlich die ganze Thematik von wegen Drohnen und autonome Geräte heute nur im Bruchteil anreißen. Aber wir haben wahrscheinlich beleuchtet, wie weit die technische Entwicklung ist. Und euch den einen oder anderen Gedankenansatz dazu mitgegeben. Jetzt ist es, glaube ich, nochmal Zeit, über die Motodrone zu reden.
Sollen wir unbedingt nochmal machen?
Sollten wir machen und wir sollten auch noch da sagen, dass es Chaosradio Express gibt.
Genau, Chaosradio Express.
Genau, also Chaosradio Express wird noch eine Chaosradio Express-Sendung zu dem ganzen Drohnen-Thema geben, die ein bisschen mehr auch in die Technik reingeht. Also ein bisschen erklärt, wie funktioniert es eigentlich mit diesen Kreimanfiltern, den Sensoren, den Brasch-Lassmotoren und so weiter. Diese ganzen Dinge wird vermutlich sogar noch vor der Motodrohne passieren, weiß ich aber nicht ganz genau. Ansonsten gibt es seit der letzten Sendung vier neue Chaosradio Express-Podcasts zum Runterladen unter chaosradio.ccc.de. Ich habe jetzt die Themen nicht alle im Kopf, aber es sah irgendwie ganz interessant aus. Klickt da mal drauf, ladet euch die runter. Chaosradio Express ist sozusagen die Ergänzung zum Chaosradio hier auf Fritz.
Der technische große Bruder.
Wo halt einfach die technischen Dinge ein bisschen mehr ausführlich gewürdigt werden können. Ja, ansonsten wie gesagt chaosradio.ccc.de, da gibt es halt auch noch mehr Details und Informationen dann.
Genau, und auch den Podcast dieser Sendung.
Genau, und am 20. September ist die Veranstaltung Motodrone veranstaltet von dem Motodrone REV. Und damit arbeitet das Chaos Computer Clubs und etlichen anderen Institutionen. Paparazzi werden da sein, etliche Mikrokopter-Bauer werden da sein. Ich hoffe, jemand von Microdrones wird auch da sein. Hab ich noch nicht erreicht. Etliche Vertreter von Politik und Wissenschaft werden anwesend sein. Wir werden Mikrokopter live und zum Zugucken dort bauen. Wir werden den Stand der Entwicklung für die Challenges, die eigentlich hätten stattfinden sollen, zu denen aber fast alle Bewerber einfach nicht so weit sind, dass sie die Aufgaben hätten lösen können. Wir werden dort einfach den Stand der Technik diskutieren, den Stand der Entwicklung diskutieren, gegenseitig Hilfestellungen geben, den neuen Termin für die Challenges besprechen, an den es dann tatsächlich wirklich um die Wurst geht. Macht keinen Sinn, wenn da jetzt zwei Leute gegeneinander antreten und beide das Problem irgendwie mehr schlecht als recht lösen. Das wäre schade, so ist es nicht gedacht. Deswegen, grob wird die eigentliche Challenge im nächsten Jahr stattfinden. Wir schätzen Mai oder Juni, sodass also auch der Chaos Communication Kongress noch dazwischen liegt, um eben sich wieder zu treffen, noch mal Update zu haben, noch mal konkret miteinander dran zu arbeiten. Die Veranstaltung wird stattfinden, wie schon gesagt, am 20. September in Finofort, Furt auf dem alten Militärflughafen Museum. Das ist nördlich von Bernau, noch die Autobahn hoch Wandlitz vorbei, Lanker vorbei.
So eine Dreiviertelstunde von Berlin.
Genau, 50 Kilometer etwa. www.motodrone.org www.motodrone.org, genau, da findet ihr auch alle notwendigen Informationen und wir freuen uns total, wenn ihr zahlreich kommt. Mitdiskutiert, mitbastelt, euch das einfach anschaut oder da einen schönen Tag verbringt. Da diskutieren wir drüber. Ich glaube ja, aber nicht viel. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht mehr, was wir genau gesagt haben.
Das ist rauszukriegen motodrone.org 20. September. Ansonsten chaosradio.ccc.de Da gibt es die Podcasts der Sendungen und auch alle anderen Sendungen aus der Vergangenheit noch mal zu nachhören. Da gibt es die Chaosradio Expresses. Hier gibt es nicht mehr viel zu sagen, außer passt auf, dass ihr nicht über eine Drohne stolpert. Danke für das Anrufen, danke für das Mitdiskutieren und danke für diese höchst interessante Sendung, in der wir alle ein bisschen was gelernt haben. Frank Rier und Steini vom CCC waren hier. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Wir machen jetzt uns vom Acker, weil hier kommen Maxwell Smart und seine komischen Beat-Bastler. Alles klar, Maxwell und seine DJs sind am Start. Die sind in 5 Minuten im Neustart für euch da. Wir sagen Tschüss bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss von mir und bastelt schön und lasst euch nicht unterkriegen.